e
morning everyone the time being 9:37
session and we'll start by um I'll open
um
hb514
representative
PL this uh bill I think is premature in
my view uh something we may very well
have to do but I'd rather have the
courts get through their processes first
I do remember the Brew I was before my
time but there was a brewhaha among
several towns calling themselves donor
towns and uh I'd rather avoid that
unless you if we had a court order the
forcing us to uh it might be more it
might be better than doing it right now
okay representative spillsbury thank you
Mr
chairman so just to review for everybody
there are actually six Bills currently
in the legislature this session relating
to swept in one form or
another and so I just want our
peripheral vision to be open Beware of
the other bills and I'm going to
mentioned them briefly uh
1686 which was uh introduced by March
Smith and I'm one of the co-sponsors
went to the education
committee and it deals specifically with
the same subject as
1514 and that is what to do with the
excess swep in about I believe there's
about 26 so-called donor communities
that collect more in swept than would be
due to them in state adequacy aid and so
there's about $29
million
um that bill was uh taken to the floor
two weeks ago without recommendation and
tabled uh all leave representative Ames
to describe uh what's in his bill that
we tabled uh
earlier uh excuse me put into interim
study
earlier and uh he also has a component
that's in representative luno um bill
which was put into interim study also so
education has taken two bills one that's
on this subject one that includes a
component on the subject and put both
into interim
study and then we have this
bill um representative fellows
Bill and uh also the one that we already
put in interim study I think that it
only makes sense to put this bill into
interim study also but then have a
session in the
fall perhaps the litigation is
further I think it's a bit optimistic to
think that the Supreme New Hampshire
Supreme Court has uh uh ruled on appeals
at that stage but we'll be
closer and I think that ultimately the
difficulty with this subject is that it
pits some towns against other other s
and I'll be frank mine my town uh
Charles Town and the other towns I
represent including unity and
particularly
Newport um struggle mightily to fund
local
education Charles toown has the second
highest real estate tax rate in the
state
Mills um our education our local Ed
20.93% six for local Ed alone so I
think I view this in two
ways on the one hand our current swept
is kind of a
fraud it uh it's a sham it it suggests
that the state is going to pick up more
of the education
cost to alleviate the burden on local
property tax and how are they going to
do it by searching local property
change
however the problem with this specific
Bill and what it's trying to attack is
that it's got a conflict and I'm very
sympathetic to the
towns that have collected excess
swept sometimes to the tune of several
million dollars for example molten
Boro and uh and this bill asks them
to just mail it on
in that's a tough thing to ask them to
do what I think we ultimately need to do
is restructure this completely and I
know that representative fellows
representative Ames are working on that
I've been involved in the education
funding
subcommittee January and February uh
where we focused a fair bit on that and
ultimately I think the focus of that
effort May center around representative
luno bill in education I think that this
needs to be part of a bigger Grand
bargain and I think it's something we
can work on and help shape in the fall
but I don't think it's going to be ready
for action until next year so that's
just my take it Demands a solution the
courts have said it's
unconstitutional but that doesn't
necessarily mean this is the right
vehicle
well thank you to representative
spillsbury I think that was a good
overview um and
I I'd say bottom line I share in the uh
thought that uh we need to work on
this um some more and that the interim
study vehicle is the essentially the
only one we have
to um
to not put aside this bill but put it
into a
process um where it will join other
bills and um we have to understand that
we in this Committee in conjunction with
the education committee and the finance
committee need to find a way of working
in a serious and thoughtful way to
achieve a u both a a full understanding
of the options this is a good option
here but is not by no means uh I'm
referring to House Bill 1514 by no no
means is it a
comprehensive uh response but it the
idea of a local contribution is uh is um
an important idea that we need to look
at um I I think uh having having said
that I think it's we have an opportunity
we have guests here in the audience who
uh know a great deal about pieces of
this puzzle that we're trying to put
together uh the Attorney General's
office is here and um Dr is here um and
um I'd like to know myself what the
latest understanding of the uh requests
for stays in the litigation is uh from
the Attorney General's office um if
there's no stay well we're under the gun
and we uh maybe we're not uh directly in
the line of fire but we we will be um
and um with respect to
Dr um the question of swept and how it's
handled uh if there are questions about
that we should explore them while we've
got an opportunity
um
yeah thank
you anyone else before we invite okay
yes
representative thank you Mr chair I I
would just like to um add that if we
were to keep this bill it would need
some work done to it because there are
some technical issues particularly
related to timing of how how the state
would go about
um processing receiving and processing
the excess and the fiscal note Dr uh
cover covered some of that and I what I
see is
a a timing issue it it would need the
spill would need some a significant
amount of work to get it to do the
intent thank you representative
Aly thank you um I believe that the
Supreme Court being the last court of
authority on this on is going to be as
19998 I think it was when they told us
in
December that and we were going to have
to solve education
funding um and give us in into next year
to figure this out
um I presume that they are going to act
by then so
on keeping the bills that some of the
bills the bills that make the most sense
within a particular category um and
working on them seems like a much better
um I guess we'd have to do it as inter
from
study um than trying to do something
now that may or may not be something
that the court would think would be
interesting thank you uh yes represent
El thank you Mr chairman I reluctantly
agree um I think the fundamental
question that we're that we need to look
at is who is responsible for educating
our
children do we see the community that
it's based on as being limited by
geographical Borders or do we say that
the entire state has a commitment to
educating all of our
children and I'm hoping that the courts
will give us some clarity on that and
the interim study will as well thank you
thank you I think we're going to invite
up uh Department of Justice and uh ask a
thank you chairman thank you committee
this is uh Sam garland from the
Department of Justice nice to see you
all again thank you Mr Garland um
representative Ames would you like to
ask a question of uh Mr
Garland yeah
um what's the
latest from last week um so since our
meeting last week which point uh there
was a motion to stay that we had filed
at the Supreme Court um the plaintiffs
have objected to that motion they had
been directed to do so by the Supreme
Court by 3M on Thursday and they
objected actually Wednesday night so the
motion is briefed in pending with the
court um uh Senate President Bradley has
also filed um a motion for leave to
appear as an amus in support of our
motion to stay and has filed a motion or
excuse me a memorandum in support of
that position as well um just last night
I believe the the plane of subjected to
the request for for him to participate
as an amicus and that that remains
pending with the court as well um we
don't have a ruling from the court
sitting here right now or at least we
didn't as of of 10 minutes ago the last
time I checked um the Supreme Court did
order that the plaintiffs respond U more
rapidly than the court rules would have
otherwise allowed they they requested
their response um several days before uh
the the the normal deadline that would
have existed under the rules um it's
always dangerous to read Court te leaves
but I do tend to think that suggests
that the Supreme Court is looking at
this it it knows the Motions pending and
it's taking it seriously um but sitting
here today there's there's no ruling yet
in the conval motion to stay um in the
Rand case the the case involving U more
directly the swept um the Coalition
communities have filed both a notice of
appeal and a motion to stay the order um
the trial Court's order there uh we
received the motion to stay at the end
of last week and we're assessing that
internally at the Department of Justice
uh no response has been filed to that
yet and the Supreme Court hasn't taken
yet any anyone else have questions from
Mr G yes
follow um so the other question and you
you spoke to this before but uh now
you've had more activity
um relates to the timeline for uh
referenced by representa only uh for
maybe getting to a uh let's let's assume
a stay
and that the court then um um rolls up
its sleeves and addresses the issues
that are raised in both cases
um any sense of I I know it's unfair but
any sense of of a of how long that's
going to take um thank you
representative Ames so so it's hard to
to predict exactly the time frame on
that both because it it we don't have a
even a briefing schedule yet in either
of the cases and these are complicated
issues that the court obviously we
expect to take seriously and will
require some some deliberation um
generally speaking once we file a notice
of appeal which will be due next week
the The Briefing schedule would come
within the next 30 or so days if no
party seeks to expedite to the appeal
and you know I assume all parties are
considering whether it makes sense to do
that there's there's a tension between
Expediting an appeal of the sort to get
an answer but making sure that the
parties in the court have the time uh to
consider it as as as much time as as
necessary um once the appeal is fully
briefed um typically a brief would the
initial brief would be due 30 days after
the briefing order a follow-up brief or
an answering brief would be due 30 days
after that there'd be some time for a
reply if there were no extensions so
we're
talking two and a half to three months
just for briefing the Supreme Court
would almost certainly hold an oral
argument in a case such as this um or in
cases such as this they did back in 2019
when the conval case was up there before
and obviously have and just about every
Claremont in in London da case that was
before the court as well and then after
that the the ball is really in the
Supreme Court's hands to determine how
long um it takes to to draft an opinion
and you know we've seen opinions as
quickly as a month or two in in certain
cases and opinions can take over a year
and it depends really on how long the
Supreme Court um takes to deliberate and
draft an opinion that a ma majority of
the justices um are comfortable with and
so that that is a non answer to your
question but but the short the most
direct answer is it is certainly a
matter of months and and appeals it's
not uncommon for them to take you know
upwards of a year um I think everyone on
our end and on the plaintiff's end and
and I assume on the Court's end too
understands the importance of this issue
and understands that the legislature um
has had to Grapple with it in the past
is grappling with it now I don't think
that's lost on anyone and so to the
extent that has an influence on on the
timing um and it certainly may that
that's that remains to be
seen
all right anybody
else seeing none thank you oh did you
have a question I just wondered how
would um a regular citizen keep track of
all these steps if if they if they
happen to have enough um knowledge of
the law to understand what they even
mean for sure so there are a couple of
different ways um representative fellows
and thank you for the question um the
Supreme Court um has a an efiling system
that allows uh people who have the
ability to to to sign in and so attorne
attorneys can sign up for signin
information um but I believe and I don't
want to overstate this but I believe
that any member of the public can to or
at least can track a case where you can
access the briefing you can certainly do
so at a kiosk at the Supreme Court but I
believe there's there's an online way to
do it as well um sometimes the Supreme
Court will post uh the the the relevant
filings on its website depending on the
case that's within the Court's
discretion and I'm not aware of it
having done so here um and then more
generally the the Press has been
tracking these cases very closely for
the the the fulltime that the conval
case has been pending since 2019 and so
there have certainly been um Regular
press updates um up to including you
know our most recent filings in our
meeting last week um that that are
keeping fairly close track of the
well thank you um okay okay thank
you does anyone have should we bring Dr
up does anyone have specific questions
right
good morning my name is Keen M Wong TX
policy council with the
Dr my name is Bruce canu I'm the
supervisor of the municipal Bureau at
Dr okay my my question is
uh is relates to when Dr will be issuing
updated um reports on
adequacy and um and uh if you're doing
it equ and Equalization ratios for the
property tax
my understanding from what I see on on
the uh uh internet is um on your
site is um that in the
adequacy uh spreadsheets and
calculations the uh where property
valuations play a part now um the
property valuations that are used used
and the equalization ratios that are
used are uh derive based on uh April 15
2022 um values and
um I
un understand that those values would
have been picked up a year later or so
but now we're
into another we're into April
momentarily is that when we're going to
get updated updated Equalization
ratios
yeah thank you representative Ames um
the equalization
ratios necessary for uh a portioning the
the the State education
tax are developed from the local
assessed values which came into Dr last
fall and that Equalization process
hasn't until May 1st of this year so the
2023 equalized values are still in
process um and you are correct that the
the swept warrants that are
currently uh in the hands of the
municipalities um utilized the most
recent available equalized values at the
time which as you noted were the uh
the local values from
2022 that were finalized as equalized
2023 and at this point
[Music]
um under normal and current conditions
and and and so forth
um the next swept
warrants would begin their uh process of
being calculated and created sometime
after May of this year when those 2023
equalized values have been um um
forwarded and the the short period of
appeal by municipalities is concluded so
generally by around early
June that's where we stand um today as
we sit here um follow follow
up um
so the intersection with doe uh doe
picks up the information from Dr it
includes it in its calculations I see
Mr I don't dare say your last name Sir
Mark
M something like that way off um picks
up doe picks up um your values and um
how soon after
you well the values that show up right
now are April
2022 that's the the indicator and I
understand that there's another year of
processing I think anyway um when do
they pick up the new
values well if we want to go back to the
the process that's already been
concluded uh in like I said May of 2023
the 202 two local assessed values had
been equalized at that point Dr can
calculate um the swept
taxes and that data or that information
is then shared with uh Mark and his team
at at
education for use in um the work of the
adequacy aid estimates for the next year
so at this point uh the equalized values
that helped create the swept warrants
that are out right
now were utilized by education and and
I'm sure um if needed Mark can and
confirm
or further expand on this they were
utilized last fall as education had to
get ready to give the districts the
estimate of of um adequacy for what is
now the fiscal Year we're we're
in so at this point again what would
happen in the spring under existing law
is that Equalization would be finalized
sometime in May of this year uh the
municipal Bureau team would begin the
process of calculating what would be the
swept warrants used in
2025 and when we have that data
developed we'd be able to share it with
education for use in their work in
developing the next set of adequacy
estimates so it's it's an ongoing
process where in effect at times you
have um one swept already developed and
in having been forward and soon
thereafter the next process is
beginning okay I understand that thank
you um I just want a comment the reason
why this is so important why I'm asking
this question is that these values
change
and uh real estate values particularly
changed significantly over the last
several years so that
um there will be a change and sometimes
it will be significant some communities
have gone way up um and
um as we and then they factor into
what's important to us which is um How
uh much money a school district is going
to get and that's related to ratios like
the ratio of free and reduced price
lunch kids to the equalized value in a
particular Town um and both of those
numbers
are difficult to pin down these days but
uh that's why it's important and that's
why I'm pursuing this and uh I would
like to hear for a moment from Mark M um
about uh his uh the numbers he's using
and when he hopes to have the next set
of
numbers representa
elme before that could I ask another
question to Mr caner yes sure
uh we for two three years now have been
in a situation where fewer and fewer
houses were being sold at higher and
higher ridiculously higher
prices how have you dealt with that in
trying to figure
out particularly I
on well in any case you're going to have
a whole lot of houses that are never
going to sell for those prices but which
are equivalent to the ones that are are
being sold for 500,000
1 million 5 million uh and at some point
this bubble is going to
burst at least if not we're all stuck in
the same places we've been in for a very
long time about I don't know what
percentage of the population that is but
it's pretty
high thank you representative Aly um I'm
not qualified to address the specific
question uh that work is done in the
equalization
Bureau and I am not trained in that
science as a were so I don't I do so you
aren't the head of the equalization
Bureau no um no I'm not but um I'm sorry
that is he is he in Dr she he it at at
this point it would probably uh want to
be assistant director denor or director
green who would address Equalization
specific
questions yes representative fellows um
yes thank you um Mr canor I think one of
the things that you said when you were
trying to go through all the years you
can you speak into the microphone when
when you were doing all the different
steps yes is I I heard you refer to um
setting the tax rates but I think that
at that point it was actually the
warrants that are going out and there's
a distinction between the warrants say
how much is needs to be raised from
taxes in the ensuing year the rates
don't
actually are not actually set
until shortly before people get their
start to get their bills their tax bills
their estimated tax bills thank you
representative fellows if I might I'll
just return to where we are right now
there are warrants in the hands of the
municipalities to raise a certain amount
of swept taxes in their
municipality for from Municipal bureau's
perspective we're talking about the tax
rates that will be set this
fall um again it is a long process from
the time the original locally assessed
values come into uh Dr in the fall of
2022 creating warrants that are are
going to be used um to equalize values
that will be available in May of
2023 helping create warrants that will
be used in
2024 on 2024 you know final tax rates
this fall so it is a long process and
during which again it cycles and begins
again so
it's it gets um decently complicated to
try and explain I know without a
timeline in front of all of us
so the warrants that are out right now
for argument sake in in a hypothetical
municipality to raise a specific amount
of
dollars that will be reflected in the
tax
municipality okay um yes represent
spillsbury thank you Mr chairman I'd
just like to clarify two things
hypothetically if this bill 1514 was
passed in this session it has an
effective date of July 1
2024 so the earliest that this would
have any impact is in the cycle that
leads
towards uh the warrants that are set in
May of 25
right I'm just talking about timing
right um if the law went into effect
July 1 then we would operate under the
new law in preparing the Warr the swept
warrants that would be issued by the
commissioner by December 15 and be used
in
2025 right and because those um those
figures are set in May it would affect
the taxes that are set in November of 25
that's that's how far lag time we're
talking about corre the second thing I
wanted to clarify is
that this specific question regarding
what happens with excess swept the bill
proposes that excess swept is no longer
retained in the towns it's sent to the
state does not change the amount of the
swep which is 363 million does not
change the allocation to the various
towns based on um equalized
valuation does not change the amount
that each town has to raise off of their
real estate taxes it only changes the
disposition of the more or less 29
million aggregated excess swept from the
various towns that have an excess
and the 29
million more or
less does not go back into the same pot
and rearrange
the allocation of the $363 million
burden it just goes into the education
trust fund goes back into the open pool
so I'm just I want wanting to lay this
out and ask you do I have it right um
this does not change and will not in the
future change the allocation of the
swept dollars and the burden that each
tax thank you representative bilsbury
yes you have you have outlined it
correctly okay um and I'd just like to
make a a third observation and that is
it's it's generally understood that the
swept tax is a fixed amount for every
town but in fact the whole process of
applying the equalized valuation results
in different rates so the Statewide
average is
a122 in my town in Charlestown for for
example it takes
a145 per thousand to raise that so the
the amount that each town uh ends up
taxing in this process does vary and and
and the the fuling point of that
variation is whether you're property
poor property Rich relatively speaking
so that $145 in the case of Charlestown
sorry I was I was going beyond my
question to you okay that's that's more
of a comment to the committee thank you
okay
um okay um let's um I think we're
getting to the point where we'll take
one more question from representative
elme Al this is just a question of so
you said the director of Dr or the
assistant director Diane Kerr I didn't
get the name uh the assistant director
is Adam
denor there is why I didn't get the G
r thank you and he runs the equalization
Bureau which I can't
find except a brief description of what
it
does uh at at present um the
equalization Bureau um questions should
be directed to either assistant director
you okay um I'd like to move on unless
somebody has a burning question yeah I
would just like to say that I think it's
important that we start to educate
ourselves about that particular
process yes it certainly is would be
helpful um I know representative Ames
you had said you want to hear from Mark
m is that still the case that is the
quick hello my name is Mark manganello
Mark m is just fine uh I'm with the
Bureau of school Finance uh with the
Department of Education
um representative Ames was discussing a
lot of the lag time with the
equalization process um that certainly
does exist as far as the ms1s coming in
in September which is calculating data
back from April and then getting
equalized throughout the spring and then
being handed off from Department of
Revenue to education to build budget
estimates in a future fiscal year so
when you look at that whole time span we
are now talking about April 22 impacting
fiscal year 25 so there is um certainly
there is is um a wide span of time in
that in that um data from data
collection to data use essentially um
and representative Ames brought up good
points about how important Equalization
data is so it is used in calculating
swept and swept is used in calculating
adequacy payments as far as state cash
that goes to school districts so uh
another thing just to back up a little
bit I know there's a lot of people on
this committee that are very well
studied in school funding but just to go
over the basics of adequacy real quick
the adequacy calculation is a state
determined number that is the cost of an
adequate education that the state has
determined each School District needs
and it's looks at student metrics um and
just to go real simple the base amount
so each student under current state law
needs in fiscal year 24 needs to be
funded
$4,100 um so that's base adequacy Aid um
there's also differential Aid components
wrapped into that constit tional
definition of adequacy that the state
has determined um students that are free
and reduced price meal eligible um
experiencing poverty essentially um sped
students Etc um but what we're doing is
calculating That Base Aid all those
differential Aid components and we're
coming up with the cost of inadequate
education so if we tally up all your
students and all the uh metrics we might
have a cost of inadequate education that
is a million dollar but the state does
not cut a check for a million doll to
the school district before they cut that
check they look at how much each
Community raised and swept and so if
your swept was swept was $500,000 and
the cost of inadequate education was a
million do the check would be
$500,000 so it's important to know that
swept is determining how much the state
pays in cash um which is using
Equalization data also Equalization like
representative Ames pointed out is using
the extraordinary needs Grant which is
poverty metrics over EV data um also
Equalization data is used in cooperative
apportionments for those that live in
Cooperative apportionment some of you
distribute Appropriations based on EV
data and so the key thing is is that EV
data is extremely important there is a
lag time um so you could propose
changing that lag time um but I just
want you to understand the tradeoff of
of having a more quicker using more
current EV data so the benefit is you
have more current EV data and so it's
more responsive to changes in the data
which we've seen year-over-year changes
in EV data of 18 % since covid um which
is a lot it's it's pretty pretty pretty
wild when you look at the you know
50-year data set um uh the average is
around 7% so um in during the 2000s
bubble we never got up to 18% so the
data is really really intense right now
as far as growth year-over-year um but
if you had more current data the
challenge you would have the tradeoff
you'd be losing is less accurate budget
estimates coming out of the Department
of Education because we wouldn't be be
able to forecast future years with the
swept data we already know exists we
would have to forecast out swept in the
future um it would be
uh uh when we set taxes or really would
it would it would impact the way really
would be impact the fiscal year 25
budgeting we just did so I would not be
able to use the swep data that I know is
going to exist so districts would build
their budget based on um potentially
unreliable swep data so that would be
one of the trade-offs is everyone would
be building their budget off basically
estimated EV data so if you if you bring
up that um if you shorten that lag
window that would be the trade-off you
would have less accurate
estimates no I'm I'm satisfied
okay represent PL I was about to say
this is fascinating and it's subject
material for the for the uh special
committee on education I'm not sure what
has to do with this bill right now
that's
all any other follow-up questions um Rob
zy well I thought we were using this to
try and discuss the whole school funding
problem
um and in that
regard I would like I don't know if the
school funding group got this but to get
one of these
on these timelines from both Dr and from
from the Department of Education about
how long it takes to do their part of
the process and what they're doing in
what you just said but on paper yeah I
could put that on paper yeah that's a
good
idea okay thank you thank you appreciate
it yeah
um I do have a brief question for Dr
again about the equalization
data
about whether okay thank
Mar back when we started
this uh there were
towns that would put their property
assessments onto a large sheet that
covered several uh walls of paper and
make the Dr deal with that because they
didn't want to provide it at all on I
know that kind of thing has gone away by
now on to what extent have you been able
to speed up the process and
is well um thank you do you have proper
computerization
and I'll go out on a limb on behalf of
Municipal and property Division and say
yes we we probably have advanced into uh
using um software in some parts but I
just have to be careful because I'm not
knowledgeable enough in the area of the
equalization process so this is most of
the hangup is at the equalization
level I'm not certain hang up is maybe
an unkind word because it's
art as part of the process that Mark
just described that hopefully he'll
timeline
uh it it it takes the time it does and
it has uh certainly in my eight years
with Dr it it's been that amount of
time
um I I don't have any other comment on
the process though I'm sorry all right
thank you I'd like to wrap this up
represent fellows
um I mean I know I know the process for
doing Equalization but maybe if you
could just go through the steps about
how you equalize you know just like one
two three um I don't oh okay yeah I'd
rather not do that I think Equalization
Bureau thank you yeah thank
you all right
um within the committee are there any uh
final comments before I uh end this
close this work
session representative spsb yes just
very
briefly if I didn't think that there was
a sincere effort of foot to reform this
whole concept of SWAT I would be urging
us to move ahead and vote OTP on 1514
right now but because I do believe that
we're moving in the direction where way
and means and education are going to
have to direct grapple with this I think
it's a bit unfair to throw this out at
the donor Towns at this moment as an
interim fragment so I'm just saying this
to say I am not pushing to move this
ahead now because I have the faith that
this committee really will dig into it
in the fall and next spring
thank you representative Ames and I find
myself in the position of concurring
again with representative spillsbury I
agree with that sentiment and uh and
think that 1514 has a lot of Merit but
uh I think it needs to be merged into
this other stream of of bills and a
serious serious consideration needs to
proceed um hopefully with something like
the subcommittee structure that was
developed uh uh not too too long ago for
some of the bills in
education um so yeah thank you
representative Ames I'm going to close
hb514 okay we'll now open the work
1563 representative plat I always stick
my neck out I I put this in the same
ball of wax as the previous bill that
it's got to do with swept the reluctant
to change much of anything till the
education special committee on education
directly representative
fellows um so I'm I'm the SP sponsor of
this bill and it's really very different
from the one that we just heard one of
the things this this um bill which is
63 um has no fiscal impact on the
state it um
addresses the Rand Court ruling that
we've heard
because
um the the ruling says to the extent
that you want to use a Statewide
property tax uh it you have to figure
out what to do with that excess payment
but uh what what this bill does is it
eliminates the swept tax from the tax
bills but it
keeps um what I call a local
contribution within the the aid
calculation formula so one thing this
bill could do is get the um Rand case
out of the way and
also um narrow the discussion so that we
won't be talking about what to do with
excess swept money anymore and it might
move the process um along a little bit
smoother when we're working on how to
fund education I do have um I did have
an
amendment for this bill that address
that I I have an amendment and I passed
it out last week that addresses all of
the concerns that Dr had um in terms of
the process and it also makes a change
so that instead of calling it
local uh tax contribution it just calls
it a local contribution and I think that
that will fit really
well um into the discussion that that
will go on about how what to do with the
adequacy aid formula so one
consideration is um for sure we don't
want to get rid of this bill um but
would it be useful to go forward with
that now because it takes care of uh the
Rand issue and um it may be and I I
don't think it hinders I think it may
names um first first I I said something
earlier on when we were doing 1514 and I
was really thinking about 1563 and I
apologize the the bill that I think is
uh is novel and brings in a new idea
that's important um is
1563 and it uh um I've gone back and
forth in my own mind as to whether we
should push for early enactment of it it
would in it would as representative uh
fellas has said uh get the swept the
donor Town issue out of the way because
there wouldn't be any swept um and uh
however I also uh feel that the larger
issue needs to be part of the pitch when
addressing a sliver of the issue as does
1563 and so my feeling at this juncture
is that this bill too should go into
interim study with the other bill um and
um
and be considered in conjunction with
the bill over an education the
foundation opportunity bill which does
have the local contribution con have
embedded in it um it also continues
swept so unlike this bill but all of
that needs to be looked at as a whole as
we try to find a solution and to go down
one route uh that uh May foreclose other
options uh doesn't seem to me the best
practice given given the uh difficulty
of this issue thank you representative
elberger thank you Mr chairman again I
concur with the suggestion about putting
this into interim study I would like to
point out one thing that uh I learned
about when I served on a school board in
another state some years ago and that is
that if we look at the average annual
cost for
education and the taxes that each of us
may pay and I'm going to just point out
I have one daughter who's now
35 when her father and I
divorced each of us stayed in the
community where we were living and
between us the taxes that we paid for
her
education or that we paid on our two
houses barely covered the cost of her
education which was a regular education
no special needs no uh lunch or
breakfast support and that meant there
was nothing left over for paying to pay
for the other services that the
community provid Ed I did a a very quick
um calculation here actually my phone it
uh the average per pupil cost last year
was
$118,400
if we multiply it by 12 years let's
assume kindergarten is not involved then
that amount times 12 years means that a
child's Base education went
for1 100
91,000 if we add the cost of
kindergarten it means over
$200,000 I don't think any one of us has
paid that much for our own child's
education the folks who may move to
communities and I know it happens here
it happens in other states where people
move to schools to school districts
where the education is good and they
stay as long as their children are in
school
and once their children are done with
school they move somewhere else where
they believe that they will not have to
keep continue paying for education
because in their minds their
responsibility is done it's not done if
we assume that the cost of Education
here is somewhere around
$200,000 then if we're paying $10,000
and I'm using that as a round number for
property taxes in a year it's going to
take a lot of years to pay for a child
to be educated so the communities where
folks may have gone to
retire because they are done paying for
education and they don't want the
responsibility of paying for other
children's education need to remember
that other people paid for our children
to get educated thank
you thank
you
okay
thank you um I am going to close the um
1563 we'll now open the work session on
HB
1613 relative to trust fund for money
Water dos comments someone other than
representative PL leading It Off
all right representative PL I'm okay
representative yes I just want to make
sure I I got an email last week from
representative Muse about amendment I
don't know if that was circulated around
to the committee or or we had the
that
H when we asked last week the author
said that this amendment was the
okay what do we think what do we think
about this amendment represent roachford
did you have comments on it yes I I
I I like the concept of this um you know
considering if you were in a community
who uh you know suffered a loss or a a
catastrophe a catastrophic pollution
event and uh the state takes up a case
to mitigate that I was just surprised
that um you know as it stands now unless
it's already predetermined by the
legislature those funds go into the
general fund and the people that are
affected by that may be having to share
that those funds with other needs that
are completely unrelated uh um to to
their event so I I uh I like the concept
of this um you know he he's you know the
the fund was set up for a you know to
kind of hold the money until the state
determines for two years I don't
necessarily if that's long enough um
just knowing how things move down here
but uh I'm generally supportive of of
this concept and it appears there's no
negative um to this on on the state
general fund right it's potentially a
positive represent
before
all right I'll I'll give everybody two
this 702 H
whoops
some
aims well I I could uh point out the
change
and I think they make sense um the first
change is on the first page um lines 12
to
14 and that's an added added uh language
all monies in the fund shall be non-aps
and continually appropriated by the
Department of Environmental Services for
the purposes of this chapter and then if
you go to the bottom of the same
page the uh sentence that begins at line
30 however if the commissioner of the
Department of Environmental Services
finds that the specific type of
contamination addressed in the
settlement has already been remediated
and no longer presents a hazard to the
environment or the health of the public
the commissioner May request the state
treasurer to transfer the settlement to
one or more dedicated environmental
funds under the administration of the
Department of Environmental Services I
remember we discussed that issue so this
provides flexib
ability uh that's the intent there uh
with controls and then the last uh
change um
is uh in paragraph
um and I think wait a
minute yeah it's uh it's a slight change
right the state treasurer
um it yeah this is a little harder to to
explain
um maybe maybe representative
Army will haard well from what I'm from
what I'm seeing representative Ames it
looks like instead of transferring it
directly the IM it says to the immediate
use of the solid waste management fund
own drinking water fund now it is
um uh environmental funds under the
administration of the Department of
Environmental Services as directed by
the commission so it gives it gives more
flexibility yeah I think that's
right okay any other comments it seems
like the amendment uh has addressed the
concerns of the previous bill
okay um seeing no more comments I'm
1613 I'll now open the work session on
HB
1655 that's relative to establishing an
educator certification fund for fees
paid to the Department of
Education
comment representative fellows
um I forgot to go upstairs and pick up
the amendment that I had done for this
it's already printed and it's upstairs
the amendment um takes out the second
part of the
bill so that the only thing that it does
is um it
just the criminal history check stays
yeah it's just what's on line five and
six it has that change but the rest of
it uh goes away so there's no it's not
creating any kind of new fund um
representative alme and I sat down with
the drafter one of the things that we
found is we already knew that in two
different places in the um dedicated
funds report the name was of the fund
was different and we actually found a
third name for the fund so there really
we we could not try to um do this second
part because we we couldn't we didn't
even know what name to put in for the
fund was the the biggest issue but the
amendment is fine I just forgot to bring
it downstairs okay so we can get it uh
for the exec session representative elme
yes um we haven't been able to talk
about this but I spent
time following up on the second
paragraph um after I discovered that the
um Department really wanted this uh it
turns out that
the uh Das the administrative Services
is challenging probably the com
controller CH challenging
on
the fact that there is not continual
appropriation the department has been
the department and some of a lot of the
department language dates back a
century and it's it's uh never
apparently been cleaned up um which is
why they're I think four names for this
Fund in different places and there's
also a missing uh link from the
612 um that is it sends it to somewhere
else um
and
on I talked with alak conus the head of
um Drafting and Research
Services and and I talked to the LBA to
Mickey and who's in charge of the
education stuff they agreed it's all a
mess uh but they also
um they also realized that there is an
issue there
that the Lang existing language says the
fund is non-aps in an kind of elderly
way and it doesn't say anything about
continually appropriating which means
that if you're in the middle of a
project and July 1 shows
up and they haven't put that specific
item in the budget you can't finish the
project um and that
on I'm not sure that
there's been a problem yet where they
were denied the ability to do that but
um I've got Mickey from
lbo and
alakus working
on how can we make this
work because if we this
language here is not
appropriate for the
first
language on for some bureaucratic reason
I didn't quite understand um but it
can't be added onto there without um
fixing a few other
things
and
uh if we can I can't remember whether
this one has to be it doesn't have to be
done until the 21st at any rate if we
could put it off until we see if we can
solve that second problem that they've
got uh that they they are they did start
okay represent fellows so um can you
explain what you mean what what it is
that you think that we could
be
doing the I believe it's the comproller
but d
d is Raising questions and telling them
that they shouldn't be able to
line and what what lbo has been sticking
into the budget isn't sufficient to
allow
that representative uh
fellows so my understanding when I talk
to um um LBA I I asked them like what
does it mean what what is the
significance of having a fund that's
continually appropriated and they and
they when it's when it's already non-aps
and the explanation that I got was that
um if it's not continually appropriated
it gets a little more um scrutiny in the
budget process because the department
will have to you know um suggest just
Appropriations when they build build the
budget so I and it's been like that for
decades so I'm thinking that
it's it's O Okay the way it
is I mean if let me just interject if we
didn't if this and I'm not suggesting
this be the case but if this bill was
itl wouldn't you still have the same
concern because the only thing that's
changed here is the yes you would still
have the same concern
yes and it's one that apparently has
been raised but I it must be the
comproller
uh it's Das they said Das has has
brought this
um the the way to fix
it without fixing this is that education
has to remember for every one of their
of their um items like this
to put different language into the
budget the department on lbo has been
fig realized there was a problem decades
ago apparently and has been putting
language into the budget which doesn't
please the comproller
so given that it's been decades then
it's sounds like our what is the
immediacy not that not that it shouldn't
be solved but what is the immediacy to
solve it right now I mean it sounds like
rather than rushing that solution which
sounds a
little complex given that it's extremely
complex so I my my feeling is it's the
likelihood of that getting solved in the
next week is Slim and I'd probably
rather see this not be rushed and come
up with a new solution next year yeah
well I I don't think they're rushing it
but representative fellows oh so so I I
agree with that to you know the the
issue with the comp troller take care of
that next year or maybe the department
and L LBA can work it out but we do want
to pass the top part of it because last
year I think it was I'm pretty sure it
was last year a bill passed that said
the dep Department of Education should
do criminal background checks on new te
teachers or maybe when they renew I'm
not sure and people have been asking for
that for ages this the top part of this
gives them the rule making Authority on
how to go about doing that so we don't
want to just kill the whole bill I and I
agree with that my example was only to
make a point but I agree with that okay
represent Ames your microphone's been on
do you have a no okay yeah all right
yeah I just wanted to say that their
solution seems to be that we're going to
solve this in the dedicated fund
committee I have started looking at the
education statutes and I
and and
on legislative budget
office
and and alakus all agreed that it is a
total an utter
mess and that there's it there's um um
it's not going to be done by our small
committee we're they're trying to figure
out who's the best what's the best way
to get this
done okay thank you I'm going to close
1655 okay we're now on to our final work
session of the morning which is hp61 I
that
oh all right I'm going to start with
representative ases and then
representative
plet okay
um yeah I I just would start by pointing
out that there's no appropriation
Association with this it's setting up a
vehicle uh which um the sponsors who
develop this think is important and that
would be available to um receive funds
and set a framework for using them um
that might flow out of next year's
budget for example um so it's sort of
getting ready and um if uh if there's
some particular feature of this that
uh uh needs to be adjusted when money
comes into sight I imagine the adjusting
will be done but this uh I think is
enabling conversations to go forward and
solutions to be put on the table and uh
so I I would support it as is um and uh
note that a special committee that was
established to work on these issues uh
that worked in a bipartisan way on this
bill has uh has recommended this uh and
it has passed through the house is this
one that's passed through the house yes
it is um is the second committee bill
has uh on a policy basis said yeah do it
and um I think we should do
it
ditto uh representative
roord yes thank you Mr chairman I
uh agree with with everything uh
representative am says I I I you know we
the policy committee came up with this I
know there was some questions around the
hearing about the broadness and maybe
open-endedness of it and I was reminded
that the policy committee actually has
heard this and um the special policy
committee on this and uh and they were
the ones that put it to us in this
format so so I would support this as
well
yes representative Smith I also wanted
to reiterate the support that we've
heard for it I think this is a good bill
and going in the right direction I did
also want to mention for the note that
my wife is a child care U professional
herself so she may potentially benefit
from this but I wanted to be open about
well any other comments
representative spillsbury
I I guess I'm swimming the other
direction uh I found I find this build
to be
uh kind of bizarre uh it doesn't have
any caps it doesn't indicate any
criteria it's got a wide open range of
uh different kinds of things that uh uh
money could be granted for that are
essentially like the kinds of benefits a
major corporate employer would offer to
full-time employees and so this is going
to be done through grants from the state
and uh I have reservations about the
whole
concept representative elberger thank
you Mr chairman may I ask for uh Jackie
Cowell to come back up to the table she
you the list of please uh wait a minute
introduce yourself please how do you do
I'm Jackie Cowell from Early Learning
New Hampshire a private Statewide
nonprofit thank you thank you for coming
back and answering some questions there
is a list of eight items for which
funding might be provided and I believe
that you mentioned that all of those
items were taken from bills that had
passed in other states that's correct
senator representative elberg um elberg
we um we did find that um we went to
other states but also here in New
Hampshire all of those allowable uses
many of them were in the actual dhh
state plan of allowable uses for Child
Care Professionals and again the reason
for asking for this is the only other
way to raise the earnings of the and to
retain and recruit the Child Care
Professionals is to ask the parents the
hardworking families that are using it
now to to cover that burden and they
can't so yes other States including New
Hampshire have used federal funds state
funds uh private funds for these
uses may I thank you and is there
documentation for how these funds get
used you don't just give people money
and say have a good time with it correct
and I think that's really what we're
thinking you know the thoughtful process
that DHHS will undertake during the
rules making process of figuring that
out yes that will all be very thoughtful
and not just a handout yeah thank you um
given that I hope that some
representative spilsbury's concerns
about lack of accountability might be
you representative fellows well let let
me go to okay representative fellows
followed by representative shamard yeah
so I could could I ask can't remember
her name yeah so do do you remember
why uh this was amended by it it tells
me in the F the house special committee
on child care why it was amended
to initially it said that that HHS would
would administer this program but it was
changed to to say that a designated
entity yes and and so DHHS has there's a
lot of um work on their plate around
family affordability a lot of policies
that changed last year and they've been
doing grants throughout the pandemic as
extra um effort on their plate and so it
really is something my I know um Karen
he Hebert is here from DHHS but it's
both the prime sponsor's understanding
as well as mine that um that would be
the U most thoughtful way and the best
and most and easiest way to get the
money out the door in a timely manner to
the programs um and also the employers
the childcare employers and there's a
part in there too around um that there
would be Child Care employees this was
amended as representative disimon knows
this was repres this was amended by the
house special committee on child care to
also add that individuals could apply um
for this and um it is intended again as
it is being formed and and built and
established that that those individuals
yes good morning my name is Karen Hebert
I'm the director for the division of
economic stability at DHHS happy to
answer your question so so my concern
when I see on line 11 that um an entity
the department is going to identify an
entity to administer the program I'm
just concerned about some grants
particularly like federal grants that
give you an admin you know 10% or what
whatever it is that this would create a
problem with that if the agency wasn't
managing it do you can you address that
I absolutely can thank you for the
question uh so we've actually attempted
this both ways uh in the last few years
and one of those ways we have currently
functioning right now with a third-party
entity relates to federal funds uh and
it actually has been a very smooth
process um certainly one that uh could
arguably arguably be also less expensive
to have a third- party administer grants
like this for us the volume that we
would anticipate for applications for
these grants uh I would expect to be
pretty significant uh and especially
over a long period of time so I believe
that having it administered by a third
favored follow so you have no concern
that um Federal money that might be used
for this would not be allowed because of
that language is that correct correct
okay thank you R
shamberg thank you Mr chairman uh just a
supplemental piece of information
concerning you know the lines 19 through
30 on this bill uh back in the fall
Governor
sonunu uh expressed his concern about
child care by uh the the industry of
Child Care by recommending a uh $15
million one-time
distribution and it covered professional
development incentives tuition
assistance student loan repayment and
other uh approved purposes and I think
that his leadership is showing that we
do need to do something this is an
economic issue for this state when work
Working Families cannot find uh uh child
care and quality child care they can't
go to work uh most of our Working
Families are two
parents a lot of our Working Families
Are One parent and our employers are
looking
for looking for people to work so this I
believe is a necessary fund so that we
can when money becomes available from
whatever Source it will be ready to be
used and I think that Governor sonunu
when he talked about the definitions of
how it to be used I think gives us a
good direction that we should go as a
committee representative Aly thank you
and I wanted to get back to lines
on 12-
14 it does say that if the employer
fails to apply within three months after
an employee has come to them and asked
for them to help on that the employee
can apply directly to your
department on so the The Entity wouldn't
be involved at that point it looks like
but you just said the entity would be
involved and that is the intent to
include any employees that would
ultimately be interested in applying to
apply Direct with the uh third party
entity that would administer the grant
so that is that is an area we will add
not represent
Ames I think you are going to say that
the department is comfortable that that
this section can be administered by The
Entity and that the awards
um would be on behalf of the department
so this language is sufficient as I read
it to cover the situation that
representative Aly is concerned
about but it says the employee shall be
eligible to apply directly to the
department for grant
funding it does
um I'm not concerned about that I
believe the department has the
discretion to set up a a process
for responding to that application and
can use this entity for that purpose
that's my
understanding do you have I should
quickly add do you have any concerns
about this have you thought about this
issue I I have uh thank you for the
question I have certainly considered
that and I think you could go either way
if the department is
uh overseeing the fund and and the grant
distribution itself uh we certainly are
within our means to contract with a
third- party vendor um so long as there
is an appropriation to do
so for both whether it's the provider or
the
employee to repres to representative
aly's Point couldn't that line lead
to just a barrage of applications to
DHHS because there's a lot of small
employers who aren't going to be able to
handle
this yes and I I would expect and be
that and would you need extra funding
extra employees to handle that we
usually estimate that if we are to use a
third-party uh vendor to administer or
conduct any business on behalf of the
department we typically uh estimate
about 10% of any particular um fund or
benefit that is being distributed that
the 10% of that fund would essentially
cover the administrative costs for that
vendor to administer the
fund representative PL just want to make
taxes representative
ducet couple quick
questions do you know what the deficit
or have a rough idea of the deficit of
child care providers there are now I
know it's not relative to what we're
talking about right
now if if You' to venture
a guess because it's in your per so uh
the department tracks uh through the
childcare licensing unit the number of
licensed providers in the state which I
think is uh more or less of 700 uh which
has been a pretty steady number for the
last uh couple of years um you know I'm
also aware that we're not able to track
the number of unlicensed or rather
licensed exempt programs uh in the State
uh so that is an unknown number and
whether that has been increasing or
decreasing I'm sorry I'm not able to
report and do you know if if I'm sorry
would would you know if this legislation
would apply to those
non-licensed employees it's my
understanding uh that it it does so long
as the
employer is registered with the state as
a licensed exempt program to accept
Child Care scholarship children so
families that are receiving the child
care scholarship which is uh a subsidy
for child care in New Hampshire so
licensed exempt providers would have to
register with the state to receive
funding to support those families so if
they are they would qualify for this
fund follow up okay and and tertiary to
this question because uh miss your your
specialty is in DHHS could you speak to
what kind of deficiencies we have say in
health
care providers if you want a a specific
RN or CNAs what what kind of I know that
we have a problem with with uh with uh
child child care providers what kind
of deficiencies we have in that and and
the reason I asked this question is that
this addresses a very specific
Workforce this cracks the seal in
establishing a fund that the people in
New Hampshire will be taxed on to
provide benefits and wages to a very
specific Workforce we have deficiencies
across every
field and it's my belief that government
is not necessarily the answer to
every Workforce
problem and I I just wonder if this is
this a part of the solution for child
care providers if it's not part of the
solution for health care
providers or ice cream vendor providers
you know and I'm being abstract in that
so I'm just wondering we have a
deficiency and I know we have a
deficiency in healthc care providers we
have a
deficiency public service with
firefighters paramedics police officers
correctional officers we all know about
that so my concern here for this
committee and I'm sorry I'm going on
about this but my concern here is is
cracking that
seal and giving a mandate and
establishing a fund that we don't know
what the dollars are you're correct
representative PL there is no tax
dollars here
yet so I have great issue with
this thank thank
you
rep representative
ER representa Al represent Aly and then
representative ER okay
on I'm sorry I didn't bring uh the
document with me that I've been reading
over the weekend which said that there
are
uh
about over somewhere between 1 and 2,000
vacancies in the child care Workforce
with those
uh uh licensed
providers and that because of that the
rooms are not used because they don't
have the staff to use them um it is very
obvious
that this was a problem before the
pandemic but it became a lot more of a
problem since the pandemic
because as in the medical field a bunch
of people got overwhelmed and
left
uh but it is also obvious that if you do
not have child care your twers per
family economy turns into a 1 point
something person economy and we don't
have enough work
Workforce for our state to prosper
and
specifically uh money to come in that we
can tax without raising the tax on
everybody so
um this is much more
directly
uh affecting the
workforce then uh
the large amount of work that would have
to be done on the medical Workforce to
to
um keep people able to come
in and I think that's why it's um been
getting a lot of attention from the Bia
from the Governor from the the um
economists
in recent years they've woken up and
realized
that especially women can't be doing two
full-time jobs at the same
time representative
ER thank you Mr chair I'm having a hard
time with this particular Bill and and
the wording that's contained there in
where this state is going to set up a
dedicated fund
it's going but that fund is not going to
be administered by the state it's going
to be administered by a third party
regarding the distribution or who
qualifies for the distribution of
funds without a set of guidelines
contained in the law as to what the
requirements
are other than they're going to be given
to somebody for something that deals
and as was stated by uh representative
walner when she sat there eventually
funded well she
did when she was asked that
question
so where are the guidelines where the
where where are the constrictions where
perimeter other than we'll make it up in
along did you have a answer for that
sure I was certainly going to make
reference to the ru making as well as
some of the guidelines that we have been
in um applying with past grant
opportunities uh or current grant
opportunities that we have now
um so I uh uh the department would be
overseeing the fund and the
administration of it but we may
certainly or if it is legislated uh we
if not legislated we certainly choose to
consider uh making use of a thirdparty
vendor to assist us to administer that
fund um so the department would still be
overseeing that fund and establishing
the guard rails or guidelines with
respect to uh the criteria and the
yes the guidelines are set up by law not
by the
agency and they're not
there as far as I can see I see them
being created in
rules but
as well we've had this discussion in
this committee repeatedly rules don't
necessarily work as well as
statute regarding distribution of
funds uh I
think one other program favored by both
the other side
has been criticized as lacking
issue just based on the experience that
we have had over the last 2 three years
with respect to grant
opportunities uh both federal and state
fund Ed um I don't see that as a concern
from the Department's perspective um but
I certainly
appreciate um uh what you are describing
and the concerns that you have with
you president
Ley thank you Mr
chair um so I just feel the need to
respond um to to comments first of all
that um often in this committee we are
told not to debate the policy that
that's not our role um so it seems that
we've turned to debating the policy and
I'd just like for us to pause for a
minute and consider the kinds of
comments that we're making
um we do fund the
police the taxpayers fund the police I
don't think that we're opposing to that
I'm not I'm not in favor of defunding
the police
um we fund teachers also I think these
are the the basic uh building stones of
civilization and as a mother who just
lived through a pandemic where I lost
the ability to send my children to
school um and I'm an educator so you
know I had the the background apparently
to educate my children at home but
discovered that that was very difficult
so yes the state has a role to play in
our society as it works right now so the
question we're asking right now is
should the state participate at all even
might we help facilitate the
dispersement of funds to child care
providers and the rules are quite clear
in this bill the expenses must have
already been incurred right and there's
a a list of eight things that those
expenses must have been spent for in
order to get reimbursed from this fund
so I think it's a very um humble request
that we support something very basic
that everyone in the state keeps asking
where are the workers where are the
workers right and we've pinpointed two
pretty big problems that we're having in
New Hampshire Housing and child care
workers must be able to access these
things in order to go to work I think
that the policy's already been discussed
in fact it's been discussed by a
committee that was specially designed to
deal with the child care problem so for
us to to devolve into debating policy on
this I I'm a little bit uncomfortable
with I just want to point out that
that's what we're doing if we choose to
do that we we may as a committee but but
let's be conscious of where this
conversation has gone I think the the
policy has been uh debated already and I
would like to move on from this Bill
thank
you all right you want to say yeah
president do set and and I
appreciate the uh representative's
comments my concern here
is
fiscal this is going to create a
dedicated
fund of that fund at some point it will
be supported by taxpayer dollars and
I've heard testimony that over 10%
because 10% is going to go to the
administration by an outside vendor of
those funds to administer this specific
fund
um it's going to you know depend whether
that's $1 or a million dollars 10% of
that is going to administer that for a
very specific Workforce what I see here
is next bium next year the next
Workforce coming up wanting to establish
a dedicated fund so they can get
supported by tax dollars for employee
stop thank
you I'll take one
more uh one more comment representa
um
Aly thank you I was also making a very
important fiscal
point if we do not
have the caretaker for the children
working in the family
working we are reducing our
Workforce to what it was less than we
had before the
pandemic on and we are in reducing our
Workforce as the
Bia also considers that's why they're
behind this and we are making it harder
for businesses to thrive to produce and
to to create Revenue that we do
tax
and
on and our whole economy to thrive we
have not been paying attention to this
in the past because on it's mostly women
and women were trying to do two jobs at
the same
time on the pandemic taught a hell of a
lot of people younger than me
representative Aly I think
representative Aly we're getting to
representative lepley's point we don't
want to discuss the policy um the the
the main point here is what is it going
to cost the state and I think we've
we've cost the state and what is it
going to gain the state okay the fiscal
component I'm going to um close the work
1611 okay now um obviously we are a
little behind on the exec session um but
I do want to get the exec sessions uh
done before we go to lunch because at
1:00 we have public hearings and I want
to keep those um on schedule as best we
can
1122 I want to firmly come back at 11:35
I'm going allow time for
um uh caucus but 11:35 I want to get
everyone back here because we want to
start in a timely manner to exact uh
these bills
so the fact that we were unable to get a
substitute for
Malloy this business of meeting on
Mondays
occasionally makes it extremely
difficult well this this week we didn't
have much choice because uh tomorrow the
speaker said we can't meet Wednesday the
room is taken by criminal justice
Thursday we have a house session so I
mean I you know we're doing the best we
can yeah okay so let's get back here by
11:35 to start our exec session thank
you the Republicans are going to cck us
in this room so I would ask um everyone
room
okay the time being 11:40 we'll start
with our exec
session and um I'll recognize
representative spillsbury for a motion
uh well let me first open the exec
session on
hb514 and I'll recognize representative
spillsbury for a motion thank you Mr
chairman uh I move interim study for HP
1514 second by representative Ames would
you like to speak to your motion yes
very briefly I think we've had very
healthy discussion I'm grateful that
we've had the benefit of the uh um
Assistant Attorney General and doe uh Dr
uh we're leaning on three different
agencies two different committees six
bills I look forward to taking this much
further in the fall thank you thank you
anybody else seeing none um I'll ask the
clerk to call the role thank you Mr
chair starting with representative duet
yes representative oler yes
representative disimone
yes uh represent spillsbury yes
representative PL votes yes
representative sodi yes representative
Meer yes representative vurt yes
representative rord yes representative
Aly
yes uh representative
Ames representative
Southworth
oh represent
here okay represent shamber
yes represent fell yes representative
Bolton yes representive hellberg yes
representive leapley yes representative
Smith yes and the chair yes and the vote
is 18 to zero with two two not voting
any objection to
consent and I'll will close the exact
session on
hb514
I'll now open the exec session on hb1
1563 and recognize representative Ames
for
Mo thank you I I'll move interim study
on this bill second Mr chairman second
by representative spillsbury and would
you like to speak to your
motion very briefly it's uh uh
essentially the same point made on the
previous bill that this is part this
bill is addresses the school funding
issue as part of a much larger picture
that we need to address comprehensively
and hopefully we'll do that uh with this
bill and with other bills in interim
study and in coordination with other
committees that are also working on this
issue thank
you seeing no
more discussion I'll ask the clerk to
call the role on HP 1563
representative ducet yes representative
erery yes represent D Simone yes
representative spillsbury yes
representative PL votes yes
representative sodi yes representative
Maser yes representative rred yes uh uh
representative bogert yes representative
Aly yes represent of Ames yes represent
of Southworth is
uh not here he's absent yeah
okay uh representative mooy is also not
present uh representative shamber yes
representative fellos yes representative
Bolton yes represent
elberger yes representative leapley yes
representative Smith yes and the chair
yes vote is 18 to zero to not present
any objection to consent seeing none
and I'll close the exec session on
1563 I'll now open the exec session on
HB
1613 and and recognize representative
roord for a
motion thank you Mr chair I move ought
to pass that's the appropriate motion at
this point is there a second second that
shamberg and then you like to uh speak
or I'd like to offer the amendment do we
do that at this point so I would like to
offer excuse me the Muse Amendment 2024
d07
02h I think that this amendment repeat
that please yep
motion
any discussion on the
amendment just want to address that yes
I I the the amendment fixed a lot of the
problems that uh we heard in testimony I
think this piece of legislation is good
um especially in light of some of the
environmental contamination issues that
we've seen in the state and we're likely
going to see more and um this would
ensure that the the folks directly
affected by
environmental contamination disasters
are the ones first in line uh for any
mitigation efforts and I would thank and
encourage my colleagues to vote for this
thank you any other
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the
0702 uh representative uh uh
representative ducet yes representative
erery
yes representative Simone yes represent
spillsbury yes represent plos yes
representative sod yes representative uh
masler yes representative roord yes
representative
Boger yes representative Aly yes
representative Ames yes representative
Southworth are not here represent Malloy
not also not here represent shamber yes
represent fellows yes represent Bolton
yes represent elberger yes represent
leapley yes represent Smith yes and the
chair yes the vote is 18 to zero two not
present okay the new uh motion is now
otpa as amended otpa any discussion on
seeing no more discussion and we will
I'll ask the clerk to call the role as
soon as he's got his papers in
order
FN
otpa
[Music]
31 okay uh rep representative uh ducet
yes representative erery yes
representative
DeSimone yes representative spillsbury
yes representative plots yes
representative sodi yes representative
Maser yes representative rord yes
representative bogert yes representative
uh Aly yes representative Ames yes
representative Southworth not present
representative Malloy not present
representative shamberg yes
representative fellos yes representative
Bolton yes representative elberger yes
representative leapley yes
representative Smith yes okay the vote
yes I screwed something up oh that's
that's see one two be 18 six seven yeah
that's how I did it
okay the vote is 18 to Z2 not present
the vote being 18 to zero any objecting
to consent seeing none we'll put this on
well and I'll close the exec session for
HB
1613 next is HB 1655 I'll open that EX
session and rep and recognize
representative fellows for a motion uh
thank you Mr chair um I move ought to
pass on 1655 and I'd like to introduce
an amendment well hold on a second do I
second second by representative Bolton
17h do I have a second on the
amendment second by represent elberger
oh it really screws me up when you have
a different second from the main motion
to the these papers aren't do we have
any objection having representative
Bolton
second they do it we'll have to we'll
have to kind of figure out why those um
because he tells me to do it in one line
and it's impossible when you have when
you have two different motions in
seconds there's got to be a well we'll
have to look into that there's got to be
a way around that yeah two
lines all right would you like to speak
to your Amendment uh yes so the
amendment deletes the part that has to
do with new language
nonlinguistic
statute already has language that makes
it a non-aps fund and um representative
alme and I um concluded that it it's
there are many
factors that um are preventing us from
it's not straightforward how to um
address the the notion of making the
fund non-lps in continuing continually
appropriated at this time because of
issues with very old statutes that have
some conflicts with the name of the fund
so what we're keeping is just the policy
part of the bill so it's just the top
section and it um just gives the
Department of Education Ru making
Authority for the new process that
they're going to be doing which is um
record Criminal record checks for
certification any other comments seeing
none I'll ask the clerk to call the role
on the amendment it's this is amendment
20241 17h representative ducet yes
representative janigian excuse me
represent Valery yes representative D
Simone yes representative spillsbury yes
representative PL votes yes
representative sod yes representative
Maser yes
representative rord yes representative
bogert yes representative Aly yes
represent of Ames yes repr of sou
Southworth not here Malloy not here
shamber represent shamber yes represent
of fellow yes representative Bolton yes
representative elberger yes
representative leapley yes
representative Smith yes and the chair
yes the vote is 1802 not
present the vote being 180 are this is
there an issue with consent seeing none
wait a second oh I'm sorry was Amendment
only yeah let me 18 02 we have to have a
separate vote
course and who is is there any um
otpa seeing none the clerk will call the
RO in one second I
can yeah okay uh this is on the otpa
mission 1655 FN uh representative duet
yes represent spillsbury
yes represent did I start excuse me I
screwed up representative
erery I suppose representative D Simone
yes representative PL votes yes
representative sodi yes representative
Maser yes representative rord yes
representative Boer yes represent of Aly
yes represent of Ames yes represent
Southworth not
present uh and Maloy represent m not
president represent shanberg yes
represent fellows yes represent Bolton
yes representative elberger yes
representative
leapley yes represent Smith yes and the
chair yes the vote is
1802 not present now is there any
objection to consent seeing none that'll
well and I'll close the exact session on
hp1
our final bill to consider in this exec
session is HB 1611 which I'll now open
the exec session
of and recognize representative
spillsbury for a motion thank you Mr
chairman I move
itl do I have a
second second representative
motion yes thank you Mr
chairman I I think that we understand
that there is a problem with the child
care
Workforce I think we understand that uh
the policy committee has uh laid out a
broad suggestion here and uh and the
house has acted on it sent it to
us but as I look through this bill as
it's written I see no
appropriation I see an indeterminable
fiscal impact I see another non-aps fund
I find no figures no
caps I find no qualifying criteria but
rather open mind open ended rulle making
Authority and that's a very very broad
uh grant for us to make of State
taxpayers
money and then to be uh managed in ways
that we're not entirely sure of with the
designated entity that leaves too many
issues it's not a budget year this is a
bill that could be Rewritten and give
given much more meat on the bones for
reconsideration next year in a different
form thank You Ren PL I uh reluctantly
will go along with this itl I saw a lot
of Merit and there's a real issue going
forward but uh all of the reasons
represent spillsbury laid out for all
the stuff that isn't in there has
convinced
me representative
shamberg thank you Mr chair I'm going to
speak again
this itl the policy of House Bill 1611
FN has been approved by the house
special committee on child care and
received approval by the house and was
referred as a second Bill to house Ways
and Means the ask is for the creation of
a childcare Workforce fund that can
accept any private state or federal
money this fund creation would dispense
Recruitment and Retention grants to
eligible Child Care employees Governor
sonunu has approved a one-time
allocation of $15 million to distribute
to childcare employers for a variety of
approved purposes as seen on page one
lines 19 through3 this bill on the
creation of the fund is an economic tool
that will assist and helping employers
retain a more educated professional
Child Care employee which will then
assist our community Employers in
knowing that their employees with young
kids can find more reliable child care
which in turn sees a more dependable
employee being a steady Workforce
employee for them the benefits of
creating this fund will allow for
options that the state can use to help
decrease barriers to access child care
and not see our working class Workforce
leave or stay out of the workforce of
New Hampshire thank you Mr chair thank
you representative Aly thank you
on the reason for putting this bill in
this year was so that there would be a
framework for which HHS would write
rules which would then
allow
the the funding of it next year with it
fra with a framework with guidelines
with all the things that you're missing
um
they can the agency that is supposed to
be that is doing this is learning by
doing this year they have 15 million
they are they asked for uh applications
they have they are looking at the
applications they will be making grants
this year uh so hopefully they will do a
good job of writing the
rules um without the stimulus
of of this bill they probably will not
be writing the rules we heard from
someone from HHS the other day who said
if there's money and then someone else
said we just have to find the money
inside the
department to write the rules because
there's no money in this there's no
money in this but this does have a
substantial effect on our economy and
therefore on our
revenues uh in the
future and on there is ample evidence
that this is needed in order to expand
our Workforce back to where it was
before the
pandemic um relative to our population
that is is
um
and I hope
that that we will be able to defeat this
itl and go ahead and do what the revenue
committee is supposed to do and vote for
this bill so that next year on which is
a budget year things can go forward more
quickly thank you
thank you representative
Rochford thank you Mr
chairman I think um I made it clear
previously what I feel about the policy
uh on this bill um a wise colleague of
mine recently said we shouldn't let
perfect get in the way of good although
the policy is isn't perfect it's good um
but looking at the need of the why we
need the policy there's a crisis in
health in in child care and it it
whether it's hiring maintaining
facilities getting
registered a lot of that's
self-inflicted by us we've imposed rules
and regulations and and
requirements upon this this group of
providers in our state that almost puts
them at a disadvantage from day
one so do
we how do we approach that do we do we
put a put a bandaid on it or do we tear
it apart and take a closer look at it
that's a question for this committee
that this came out of the first
committee and I trust that they'll
continue to do
that
um my colleagues have highlighted some
things about the finance part of it and
one of the things that was Illustrated
to me is a bill that we just pass 1613
establishing a trust fund was very clear
what happens to the money if it doesn't
get spent
where does it go how how long does it
sit there unused and these are all valid
um fiscal concerns and uh responsible
questions um and questions I think that
you know our committee that's where we
should be focused on and that's not the
policy because the policy came out of
the first
committee
um that all said I'm going to
reluctantly support the itl
thank you representative elberger thank
you Mr
chairman sorry uh one of the things that
I mentioned in our hearing last week was
that the concern
about uh accountability and no cap is a
situation that we have spent to date
about $60 million if I'm correct for
Education Freedom accounts for which
there is is likewise not not only no cap
on the spending there's also no
accountability unlike this bill for
which there is accountability we know
where the money would
go
um we already provide tax advantages and
in that way public money to businesses
in the form of writeoffs on equipment or
um sorry this is not my my areas area of
expertise but we allow T businesses to
write off items that regular citizens
simply can't if I want to
buy a copier and printer for my home
office I pay for it and that's it if I'm
a business and I'm using it for my
business I can get a write off for it we
are supporting businesses with our tax
dollarars and that that way we also
provide benefits Financial benefits
State money to uh retirement funds for
police and
firefighters the idea of this bill uh
providing benefits to one particular
industry and who knows what kind of
slippery slope that's the beginning of
if we're concerned about that we're
halfway down the hill already thank you
thank
you any more
comments seeing none I'm going to ask
1613 HB
1611 did I say you said 1613 oh I'm I
apologize 16 11 okay thank you Mr chair
calling the role uh starting with
representative duet what is the motion
the motion is
itl yes representative
oler yes representative D
Simone reluctantly yes representative
spillsbury yes reluctantly Fred PL votes
yes representative sodi yes represent
Maser yes representative rord
reluctantly yes represent
bogert
yes uh representative
Aly no and
protesting a representative Ames no
representative
Southworth is not present representative
Malloy is not president Representative
shamber no Representative fellos no
represent Bolton no representative
elberger absolutely no represent of
leapley no represent Smith no and the
chair
yes the vote is
present okay this concludes the exact
session on HB
1611 is is there a a manari report yes
right by who who's going to do The
Minority Report between the two of us
we'll solve it I have to write
one
already all right so representative
shamber um
okay all right
um next up is uh lunch and at 1:00 we'll
start with public hearings on our seven
you
yesterday
e
okay I would ask everyone to take their
seats so we can get started here we have
uh a pretty full schedule of uh public
hearings scheduled every 15 minutes or
so we'll see if we can how close we can
that okay I'm going to open the public
hearing on on Senate Bill
delandro
uh thank you Mr chairman for the record
I I'm Senator lud aladro I represent
District 20 b Awards 2 3 4 10 11 and 12
and I come before you as the prime
sponsor of Senate Bill 324 as amended in
in the
Senate it's a very simple piece of
legislation the bill requires that the
Lottery Commission to notify licensed
Distributors of Lucky 7 tickets when
their licenses expire or or is revoked
as many of you may know there have been
significant problems with license
renewals the IRS has been way way behind
in uh 5 uh 501c3 ruls sometimes taking a
year and the clubs that that that
distribute the Lucky Sevens or sell the
Lucky Sevens are basically managed by by
elderly groups these days uh the
vfw's and and the clubs are usually
managed by older vets and as a as a
result some of them uh have missed the
dates when their renewal was due and as
a result of that have lost their ability
uh to sell Lucky Seven tickets and pull
tab tickets have been very big in the
fars particularly in the clubs for a
long long period of time and it it's a
way that they sustain themselves in
terms of helping the community and
helping the N for-profits that they work
with now I worked this over with the uh
the Lottery Commission and they were
very helpful a in granting extensions
when licenses expired because of
problems with the IRS or other other
problems and uh we know that membership
in these organizations is declining and
as a result of that it's difficult to
get people to volunteer and so forth and
so it the charitable work done by these
organizations is is uh is really
something that we can't
lose
uh they do lose the ability to sell the
lucky sevs if if U their license has
expired that's all this bill does is say
that they will be notified that their
license has expired at the due date when
it has to be renewed or if if the
license has has been uh revoked and the
only person that's notified is the
person that holds the license and indeed
Mr chairman that's the full intent of
the piece of legislation that's the body
of the piece of legislation and I hope
that you'll act favorably on it uh I
don't think the Lottery Commission has
any opposition to it it's just a
situation where they're doing their job
and the individual clubs are doing their
job and we keep the thing going so with
that I'll answer any questions you might
have and I thank you very much for your
attentiveness um so just to be clear the
the last part of this bill where it says
the commission shall notify lenses
licensed under RSA so forth if the
license is revoked or suspended are they
not not notified now well that's been a
problem so I want them officially
notified like you're not in statute
right okay put it in statute as it is
for driver's license
registration and follows that that line
and the and the rationale is many of
many of these people are are are moving
along in in terms of years and this is a
good reminder it allows them to keep
functioning uh and as I said the the big
problem is really uh with the IRS and
that's something that we can't handle
but at least we can handle the state we
don't want those licenses thrown out
because of a problem okay thank you
questions represent elme yeah uh that's
same section on they have to
notify at least 45 days before the
revocation or
suspension what if it's done because
somebody ran off with the
till well that's a that's a good
question that's I I think mostly it's
clerks in the towns that are doing
that at this time and the clubs are
pretty good that the the membership is
basically
veterans and guys who are close in the
organization so that's that could be a
problem uh but I don't I don't see that
as a a real a real concern at this point
in time always you always have to be
concerned but they don't they don't
generate enough money uh you know to to
do that but thank you for the question I
think it's a good one representative PL
I would just say I was treasurer of lion
San hearing Foundation of New Hampshire
Inc with over a million dollar in the
till I find it pretty hard to run away
because it's invested in
uh I think that the in the investment
agent would notify people and I'm bonded
and so any kind of sizable money they'd
be
bonded represent Al yes
um well we're not supposed to have this
this discussion now but but I doubt a
bonded well and it's a good point I I
they may or may not but I think
generally speaking they probably out B
and I think you're correct they
volunteers they they're they're retired
servicemen in most instances they're
American legiance they
vfw's uh it it's these posts that that I
want to protect uh so that they can get
their licenses renewed in a timely
manner it continue to function doing
what they what what they do in terms of
supporting the Charities that they do
if could there be a situation where
somebody's license needed to be uh
revoked immediately but now you have to
give them 45 days notice or is
that I I it's a good question I think if
it needed to be re revoked immediately
the Lottery Commission uh would would
address that as they as they did in the
particular situation that we all are
aware of okay representative fellows um
yes um thank you senator dandro um you
may not know the answer to this I can
probably try to ask the um Lottery
Commission but um I'm wondering if in
the first section is the intent to
notify them ahead of when their license
is about to expire because it says that
they need to send in their application
for Renewal 15 days before it expires
but the new section talks about
notifying them 45 days ahead of time
yeah yeah thank you thank you for the
question yeah that the the section we we
amended this in the Senate and it it
says no less than 45 days before sex
exploration or rejection so that do that
gives them a period of time uh which I
think okay they they they probably they
need at this point that's good any other
yes represent
berer thank you Mr chairman I I am
confused here okay applic um number two
applications for Renewal shall be
received by commission 15 days prior to
expiration and then following up on
representative fellow's
comment is uh the section expires uh or
is rejected for Renewal by the
commission no less than 45 days so if
the application is due 15 days prior to
expiration is the
commission
notifying that renewal will be rejected
45 days
before the expiration which is 30 days
before they would even have gotten an
application what am I missing here uh I
I think I'll look at the RO robot to
applications for Ral should be received
by the commission 50 days prior to
explanation unless such requirement is
waved by the commission for good cause
show the commission shall notify
licenses under RSA 287e if licenses
under the section expires or is rejected
for Renewal by the commission no less
than 45 days before such such such
expiration or or rejection just wanted
to put a time frame there so that
everybody was aware of that a that their
license was expiring or or has to be
renewed and if if it's going to be
rejected they should be notified early
also in both
cases followup follow thank you so I
then this means that if a license
renewal
applicant is not going to be challenged
on a
renewal that they won't have to to worry
they there will be no okay thank you
exactly exactly thank you exactly yeah
the idea is to keep consistency as I
said just like a driver's license your
driver's license is going to come up for
Redal you notif find it enough time to
make your appointment to get it same
thing with your driver registration you
notified at enough time to do it so you
don't you don't lose it and the problem
has been many of many of these entities
had have been losing their licenses and
and represent atives and Senators have
gone to the commission and worked with
the commission to get an extension until
things are are done and as I say the big
cfor of the situation is is the IRS
because the 5013 C's are taking almost a
year to get
else
okay seeing none thank you Senator thank
you very much sir great to be with you
you next I have um Valerie King from New
Hampshire
lottery good morning my name is Valerie
King I'm with New Hampshire lottery I
oversee the division that deals with the
lucky s licensing
um I understand what uh Senator Dallas
Andro would like to do as far as
notifications we actually do provide
notifications currently we provide uh
notifications 60 days out than it that's
usually October we provide twice a um
every other week during the month of
November and once a week during the
month of December but this would
formalize that process however I did
want to point out a few wording issues
that make this a little problematic for
us number one
um about a third of our licenses are
monthly Lucky Seven licenses therefore
to give a 45-day notice they don't even
have a license yet so this should really
just apply to those having an annual or
12 consecutive month license rather than
to all
licenses
um the other thing I wanted to point out
is that as far as
and um representative El elberger um not
noted that some of these sort of how do
we give a notice before it actually
happens um so there is a little bit of
wording that should be refined but I
also wanted to point out that
541a also addresses these already um RSA
541a 29 requires that the
agency um examine an application and
either approve or deny an application
within 60
days and so and so we give notification
whether or not that was approved or
denied within that 60 day time period um
also um there's also RSA two uh 541 a30
which is the whole process for when
somebody's been suspended or revoked and
there's a whole process on notification
requirements for that as well so we'd
want to be careful not to
um create any conflicts with those
statutes which are already in place okay
thank you representative PL could you
come up with specific wording which
would alleviate your
concerns well I think
541a already addresses the revocation
the um denials but we as far as the um
notifications prior to expiration that's
that's easy enough we we can just make
it so that it is for those lenses that
have hold a license for 12 consecutive
I'd be doing us an immense favor to get
the intent of what Senator dallesandro
is trying to get pasted and make sure
you don't have any conflicts or concerns
great okay so um representative PL will
you uh take the lead on getting
that I
shall
okay representative Aly did you have
your yes representative fellows thank
you um Can can you just tell me a little
bit about the application process and
what would be the um the issue related
to the nonprofits is is
it what is the timeline do they have to
get renewed every year is it their
reporting of their expenditures and
their revenue news that has Nines in the
number is it that form that has to come
to you or what what's the process are
you referring to the IRS issues
yes so or the five five 501c3 issue
right the the 501 C uh they are required
to report do annual reports to the IRS
if they fail to do do that and for three
years they fall off the list they become
they go on the auto revocation list and
if we find that they're on the auto
revocation list they're they don't meet
the requirements for licensure followup
followup isn't there some kind of
provision for that that says if there if
the money they ex either their revenue
or their expenditures were below a
certain dollar limit that they don't
have to do that what is it what is the
number of that report you know what I'm
talking about the nine has nine in it
yeah that that'd be an IRS question I I
think I know what you're referring to
but I don't know enough to answer that
question so you don't know if they're
not required to report when it's below a
certain dollar
amount if they appear on the auto
revocation
list then so what we look at when we're
looking at licensing is that they have a
501c status either a three four there's
like seven of them
um and that they're they're currently
active so if they're on the auto
revocation list that means they lost
their um their tax exemption okay and do
do we have anybody here from the um
charitable Bureau that does the
501c3 things well let's um we can we can
check I don't know um we can check
charitable trust unit
yeah no no um representative spillsbury
thank you thank you Mr chair so as I
understand it you are proposing to
revise uh section one of this bill to
limit it to annual license renewals not
short-term licenses and not
revocations correct right and section
two without having the statute here in
front of me um I'm presuming this
applies exclusively to Bingo and Lucky 7
just like section one does is that also
e25 so 19 just applies uh so the first
section um which uh amends RSA 287 e19
that's specific to Lucky 7 only I
believe that section 25 of that same
statute applies to
both to both Bingo but not to know other
you representative fellows um just
another re question related to the
revocation list that you're looking at
is that a federal publication or the
state it's Federal it's the IRS Auto
revocation list and it's published on
okay okay seeing no more questions thank
you
you I have no more pin cards is there
anyone else who would like to testify on
a SB
324 seeing none I'll close the public
324 well now I will open the public
and
please
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee uh as you may know uh we
generally don't schedule Senators here
on Mondays and Fridays if possible so I
will be well consider me the Senate's
ambassador to the house Ways and Means
Committee for the afternoon uh my name
is Grant bossy from the New Hampshire
Senate introducing Senate Bill 363 on
behalf of Senator Dan inis 14 years ago
the legislature made the decision to end
greyhound racing in New Hampshire
determining in that this cruel sport
leads to the suffering of many
Greyhounds yet the state still profits
from greyhound racing by allowing simoc
cast betting on outof State and foreign
dog racing with no or minimal Animal
Welfare protections currently there's
only one location in New Hampshire that
offers Greyhound simoc casting the brook
in seab Brook better wager $500 million
annually on those races which cannot be
legally run here in the granite state
$500 million is a lot of money but it
only represents 1% of all bding at the
facility in physical year 2023 the state
received just under
$91,000 in revenue from greyhound racing
an amount that can be recovered many
times over with sports betting at the
brook ending Greyhound simoc casting
will not endanger the brook or
significantly decrease state revenue it
would not affect Charities which do not
receive a share of Greyhound gambling
Revenue it will bring our sports betting
in line with the values set by the ban
on greyhound racing for 14 years ago as
introduced the bill would have gone into
effect on July 1st 2025 the Senate Ways
and Means Committee agreed to an
amendment pushing that back to 2027
giving the brook three years to phase
out Greyhound simonc casting Senator
inis ask you to do this for the dogs
they may not be in New Hampshire but
they are suffering in part because of
the money Granite sters are betting if
you have any questions for Senator inis
I'll be sure to get you an answer
Senator inis thanks you for your
consideration and support of Senate Bill
360 three thank you thank you will you
take any questions absolutely okay
representative Amy thank you
um at the bottom of the first
page
on you have a definition of electronic
gaming
devices and it says in the end and such
shall include but not be limited to
video slot machines and other gambling
devices which function or are devised to
function like a video slot machine now I
believe I've used to be looking for it
um that you have not yet legalized video
slot machines in this state is this
doing
it and does that mean that are mostly
casinos are going to turn into full
scale
hos uh I think the Lottery Commission
would be better set to answer that
question from my am but this bill only
deletes simulcast dog racing on that
page it doesn't change the existing
definitions so I think the the current
definitions would hold and if I'm wrong
about that I hope the lottery
Me Maybe the lottery Comm commission can
answer that thank
you uh um any more questions uh yes
representative PL I'm just pointing out
questions well you actually you can ask
questions as long as you're not
testifying up there I'm
fine
okay anything else see none thank you
Carrie
pH chair members of the committee uh
Carrie teal executive director of grk
USA uh very honored to be here today um
uh before I give my comments just two
two brief points um to representative Al
me the language on the bottom of page
one is all current law uh this bill is
not uh amending or changing in any way
the statute regarding slot machines um
so I just wanted to clarify that uh also
um uh in the previous testimony I I
think there may have been a just a a
misspeak uh it's not 500 million being
bet on gry hun racing in New Hampshire
it's year it's 5 million being bet 5.9
million to be exact so just wanted to
clarify that point um but as as was said
uh in 2010 14 years ago uh this
legislature voted to Outlaw wagering on
greyhound racing due to Animal Welfare
concerns uh that vote happened in part
because of the support and Leadership of
several members of this committee um so
I want to thank thank uh those members
for that uh just to start with um today
uh there are only two dog tracks left in
the United States uh the company that
owns those final two tracks called
Delaware North has publicly said it once
out of Grey hun racing um there's
Federal legislation pending to end ghun
racing uh there's across the country uh
bills to Outlaw grey hun simal casting
or remote gambling on Grey hun racing or
pending those bills passed uh last year
in the states of Colorado and
Massachusetts uh a bill in Arizona which
is virtually identical to this bill has
passed the Senate and is
uh I expect to pass the house in the
coming weeks um so this is a trend the
reason it's important is uh as was
mentioned previously you know while grey
hun racing ends in the US we are seeing
foreign Dog Tracks come in and try to
appeal to American gamblers for the
first time uh the most troubling example
of this is until December uh the brook
was accepting bets from a track in Tiana
Mexico called AGA Cente which is owned
by an alleged cartel associate uh that
track has no Animal Welfare concerns and
and obviously you know we have grave uh
uh grave concerns about that track
participating in the American Market
both from an animal welfare perspective
and also just in general um when grey
hun racing ended uh simoc casting was
allowed to continue specifically to
protect the economic interests of sebr
and to serve as a bridge uh that that
policy worked um to put it in context in
2013 Gran simal casting amounted for
43% of all gambling business at the
brook today it is
1% so obviously uh that facility has
Diversified it has moved Beyond Graham
simal casting and in fact it's a
facility that is thriving um I'm here
today to ask you to Simply close the
loophole that was left uh 14 years ago
go and simply say that this legislature
already uh chose the policy that grey
hun racing should not be allowed uh
please uh also uh do not allow remote
gambling on foreign dog races uh finally
this bill does have a three-year phase
out uh as a greyhound Advocate I don't
love that um my preference would be for
gryan simal casting to end tomorrow um I
do do uh greatly appreciate the work of
Senator dandro and others in the Senate
to work out this compromise which which
allowed for this bill to pass
unanimously in the Senate and I
recognize even though that is not a date
I would have chosen that the legislative
process is a process that requires
compromise so that is that is the
legislation before you um I ask uh for
your support on a to pass motion and
I'll happy to answer any questions you
may have
representative PL yes um you State uh
tried not to allow any uh foreign
betting this this doesn't refer to
foreign or domestic it simply eliminates
the ability to simoc cast dog hat thre
it doesn't that take care of it that
that that that's correct representative
it does I I the reason I highlight the
foreign is uh I believe greyhound racing
in the next 5 years will end completely
in the United States and so at that that
point all you would have left would be
foreign Graham simoc casting okay please
point out to me uh why dog racing is
different than horse racing and why the
the abuse you concern abuse about dogs
but not horses happy to thank you for
that question representative um and
thank you for your support of the bill
uh there's two different animals if you
don't if you don't mind the pun um the
Animal Welfare Community is uniformly
opposed to Grey hun racing due to a
series of
standard practices that are intended to
uh secure the highest return from each
individual dog and uh well incurring the
least amount of cost so those are things
like intensive confinement in housing uh
the large number of injuries dogs suffer
uh the fate of greyhounds when they stop
racing the use of drugs uh just to give
one example on that uh all female
Greyhounds are given an anabolic steroid
called methyl testosterone as a matter
of course uh to reduce reduce a loss of
race days or prevent a loss of race days
uh that's an incredibly Reckless
practice the industry does it because
it's the least least expensive way for
them to prevent female Greyhounds from
losing race days uh you know by contrast
um you know there's much more money
available in horse racing for the
animals care uh the Animal Welfare
Community uh as a whole is not opposed
to horse racing um and you know each
individual horse is obviously you know
much more economically valuable than
individual dog which means it's easier
to dispose of large numbers of dogs
versus horses so I I I think there are
you know fundamental differences between
the two which is why quite frankly not
only in New Hampshire but across the
country state laws treat these two
industries differently they're regulated
differently uh and the and the the
public discourse and political discourse
around these two industries have been uh
like night and
day thank thank you any other questions
seeing none not like an attorney that's
a question I asked I knew the answer
to well we could have saved Time by
having not
answered from the witness I put the
minutes thank you thank you very much
okay next um I have uh
Kurt
correctly
thank you I'm Kurt Aron bam the state
director for New Hampshire for the uh
Humane Society of the United States and
we're here in support of this bill for
all the reasons that were just stated
and we won't belabor that I just point
out that in the Senate there was no
opposition uh in the hearing we didn't
hear I was told told by the industry
representative they were not going to
oppose this
bill uh I Hope That Remains the Same in
this body and we can pass this
unanimously if you've
ever loved a dog or love a dog Now you
kind of have to vote for this
bill that's my testimony thank you any
questions representa elme thank you
what's the
industry given that the dog racing is
now all overseas I
you Rick Newman I have a pink card for
you but no bill number so I'm assuming
it's
in thank you Mr chairman uh Rick Newman
I'm representing uh Lakes Region Casino
castleblanca Casino which is one of the
same it's the uh facility in Belmont um
and
um appear here in opposition to this
bill
it seems to me the point of banning
somal casting is to obviously impact the
industry as it still exists and has been
testified to there are only there is
only one state where live dog racing in
New Hampshire takes place that's in West
Virginia uh West Virginia's two
facilities have to run live dog racing
in order to have the casinos that they
operate so that's state law now I agree
that there efforts to change that law
and that may come to pass at some point
in time but in the meantime that live
racing is going to continue in West
Virginia and it's going to continue in
England and Australia and other places
that have it where s casting takes place
it is true that the brook is the current
only facility in New Hampshire that uh
offers sual casting either horses or
dogs however the Belmont facility is
also grandfathered under the current
statute and they were purchased a couple
of years ago or a little longer than a
couple years ago and over that time
they've been doing some Renovations and
they've been getting uh historic horse
racing installed and doing some other
things and now they're beginning to look
at the possibility of bringing back s
casting and obviously s cast dog racing
would be a big part of
that I just want to give a
quick history of this issue I've been
involved in it for many years I was was
involved in it in
2009 when um up until that point it was
required that you run live racing in
order to be able to sble cast I
represented Belmont in those days and uh
during the budget process of 2009 former
representative the late uh Steve Valen
Court approached me about the
possibility of trying to make it
optional and representative uh former
representative Kirk on the finance
committee uh wanted to do that as well
because it was costing the state money
we were happy to join that effort
because live racing was very expensive
and so in the 2009 budget it was made
optional and I think it was the
following year when uh after the tracks
had all stopped running live racing the
ban on live racing was passed but I want
to take exception to one comment that
there's a loophole this is somehow a
loophole this is not a loophole in fact
representative Cooney who sponsored the
bill to ban live racing uh Senator Ro
Burge who was well-known animal rights a
guardian uh in those days and was a
co-sponsor uh both testified in the
Senate that it was not their intent in
any way to affect SEL casting it was
only to get to stop live racing
representative Mar Beth walls who was
chair of the regulative revenues
committee also testified to that as did
the gry 2K representative who testified
quote somal cast will continue so it
it's not a loophole that this remains it
is in fact uh it was an in fact
important part of the policy that was
made I just want to say in closing
looking at the brook for instance you
can diminish the talk about the small
percentage of their total business but
the reality is in
2023 track Revenue from somal cast dog
racing was $1.1 Million 1.1 million that
was the track share that's not nothing
that's a significant amount of money and
it so the effect of of this bill were to
pass it will hurt a New Hampshire
business it will cost some people their
jobs yeah it will it will impact the
state's uh budget not a lot about
$90,000 or so but it will have those
adverse effects here it will have no
other effects anywhere else and while I
was sitting here waiting for the hearing
I just went on my phone and found about
seven places where I can bet on dog
races online and uh so if if this bill
passes people there are there is there
are people who like to bet on dog races
and if this bill passes the people who
are currently doing it in seaber and the
people that Belmont hopes will do it in
Belmont if they just if they open up S
cast will simply use these online
betting sites to bet dog racing so I
guess my point is there's there's no
particular positive impact on the world
of dog racing itself its negative impact
on businesses in New Hampshire and it
may just be enough to keep Belmont from
going forward with the idea of going
back into simal casting because it is a
significant part of the simal
cast uh business so with that Mr
chairman I would ask you to consider U
opposing this bill or perhaps send it to
study to see what else happens in the
industry in West
Virginia thank
you yes representative sting yeah uh
thank you uh would you have any
information about the current Humane
conditions of uh the dog track uh dogs
are they is there been a change in the
treatment of them I don't
sir I am aware that like other states
New Hampshire pass law for instance
prior to the Banning that required the
tracking of injuries those sorts of
things I assume that that's happened
other as I said there's only one state
left what happens in Europe I would have
no
idea okay seeing no more questions thank
you
sir I have no more pink cards on S SP
363 uh represent Aly yes uh I would like
to ask a question to the gentleman next
to Valerie
King gentleman next to Valerie King
whose name okay I don't know
um he's apparently from the good
afternoon yes junan 40 Chief compliance
officer for the New Hampshire lottery
John yes Cony c o n f o r t been
TI on we have an odd situation here
there's the this video slot machines in
this bill under horse and dog
racing
and in
D1 which is
um kind of a general gaming yes uh
statute uh
C3
on it says that there shall not be
anything like a slot
machine yes representative Aly um there
in the bill that's in front of us uh and
again this is existing language there's
a general prohibition on uh
authorization of electronic gaming
devices um which mimic slot machines
unless otherwise authorized by the
general court um so if the anticipating
your question regarding perhaps historic
horse racing machines those were
specifically authorized by the general
up so that s long sentence which starts
electronic gaming devices sh mean on is
within the ban without specific
authorization for
cor
tricky thank
you any other questions
of John Conor no seeing none thank you
sir okay thank
you and I guess if you could fill out a
pink card now that you have come
forth okay any other anyone else like to
testify on
HSB
seeing none I'll close the public
okay open the public hearing on SB 454
up thank you again Mr chairman members
of the committee I'm Grant bossy from
the New Hampshire Senate introducing
Senate Bill
454 on behalf of Senator Dan Enis the
bills Prime sponsor the shortage of
affordable housing is not only a
challenge for New Hampshire families but
an obstacle to the state's economic
growth and well-being makes it harder
for businesses to find employees leaves
gaps in the New Hampshire Workforce
we've seen critical shortages for nurses
teachers and other professionals it
makes it harder for young professionals
to stay in New Hampshire to start a
career and a family and it comes back to
housing two years ago the governor
launched the invest New Hampshire State
housing program and it's starting to
show results a recent report from the
new Hampford Department of Business and
economic affairs found that permits
issued for residential construction
increased by 18% that year the highest
in over a decade and of those new
permits 41% were for multif family
housing projects last year the
legislature made housing a priority in
the budget building on invest New
Hampshire creating new tools to boost
housing and appropriating $40 million
for affordable housing and homelessness
SP 454 Builds on that commitment
directing the state treasurer to change
the amount of money alloc ated to
affordable housing from the real estate
transfer tax from $5 million to $10
million Senator inis believes that we've
done a lot to address the affordable
housing shortage in New Hampshire but we
can do more if you have questions for
Senator inis I'll be sure to get you an
answer Senator inis thanks you for your
consideration and support of SB 454
thank you thank you representative PL
will you reading from testimony I was
and I will give you two copies thank you
very much thank you representa me yes
um permits have gone up have has
construction started on these permits I
come from a city which a few years ago
had um 2,000 units permitted and half of
them disappeared during the
pandemic I don't have data on that I can
look into it and see if we can get you
an answer thank
you
no other questions thank you very much
thank
you uh next I have a pink card for uh
Carmen
lorence good afternoon chairman members
of the committee uh my name is Carmen
Loren and I'm the executive director at
Lakes Region Community developers we're
a nonprofit developer of affordable
housing um based in lonia and uh we
serve the entire Lakes Region so we go
all the way up to Ashland Plymouth area
down to Franklin over to oopy um we've
been developing affordable housing in
The Lakes Region since the late 80s and
I'm here today to speak in favor of SV
454 um I can say from our experience you
know we put really great projects
together every year and the biggest
constraint is funding to build them so
um doubling the the carve out from the
real estate transfer tax would have a
really big impact on the resources that
are available um that New Hampshire
housing has available to put into
projects um stretching those Federal
resources that the state gets even
further every year and continuing to
make a dent in in the housing crisis so
I thank you very much um for your time
and happy to answer any questions if you
have any do you do you know actually you
may not be the appropriate person to ask
but when this bill the 5 million the
original bill went into effect how many
anyone thank you um any questions
represent
elme yeah
um what do you use the same definition
of affordable housing as is used for
Workforce housing or what's your
definition that's a great question so we
build a number of different housing
products we use the low-income housing
tax credit program to build rentals and
those are primarily for people that are
under 60% of the median income but we
also and and I would classify most of
those people as essential workers and
also seniors that live on a low fixed
income that's the bulk of our tenants um
in that housing product uh we also do
Supportive Housing for people who tend
to be extremely of extremely low income
less than 30% of the median and those
folks are often experiencing
homelessness or at very high risk of
homelessness um we've attempted to do
affordable home ownership in the past
but haven't been able to make one of
those work yet so we're we're very
interested in serving as many you know
income brackets as possible but the
states of affordable housing fund which
is where the money would go from the
real estate transfer tax um can have a
role in any of the any of the types of
housing that we build so we find it to
be very beneficial and helpful to our
you see no more questions thank you
thank you next I have
uh uh Chris Norwell I
believe
possibly I could have been a doctor with
my handwriting but alas I'm a
realtor uh thank you Mr chair members of
the committee my name is Chris Norwood I
am the current
2024 chair of the New Hampshire
Association of Realtors public policy
committee by way of full disclosure I am
also uh the board chair for the New
Hampshire Housing Finance Authority uh
which administers These funds that is a
volunteer uh Governor appointed role um
and so I come today on behalf of the
Realtors uh in support of s SP
454 um a lot of uh what my testimony is
has already been said we know we're in
the in a housing Crunch and a housing
crisis so I'm just going to skim ahead
to the critical points that are unique
to the realtor's position um first of
all I'd be remiss if I didn't on behalf
of the The Association of Realtors thank
you and other legislators for your work
last year on house B2 uh you recognize
the lack of a affordable housing and
made appropriate uh allocations of
historical funding last year however we
continue to see the need and uh the a
affordable housing fund is one of the
more flexible funds that New Hampshire
housing administers in order to create
housing
opportunities so we certainly
enthusiastically we as the Realtors
enthusiastically support this bill we
would have concerns however if there was
any increase to the real real estate
transfer ER tax and this bill does not
do that we would also be equally
concerned if efforts were made to
dedicate transfer tax receipts to
funding which is not directly related to
the expansion of housing opportunities
in our state because this bill does
neither of those things increase the
transfer tax nor does it U dedicate
funds outside of uh housing
opportunities we fully support this bill
and uh it amounts to uh a strong step
forward what our state needs for
additional housing opportunities and
with that I will take any questions
thank
you questions yes represented fellows so
I um thank you I think we just heard
that it was just it was let's say three
years ago that this first allotment of
$5 million was put in the
new New Hampshire
yeah I'm sorry I'll let you finish your
question I was what I'm interested in is
what has that money been used for can
you translate it into units built or
anything like that thank you
representative for the question and if I
could Mr chair and representative uh I
think either uh executive director Rob
dais or deputy director Ben Frost of New
Hampshire housing would probably be more
appropriate to answer the particulars of
the question and the history of the
affordable housing fund is that okay
representative thank you
yeah sounds good um representative PL a
clerk question you were a little faster
than I can type um you said you were
2024 chair of New Hampshire Realtors
public policy committee did I get that
correctly yes what was your secondary
role uh I am uh the board chair for New
Hampshire Housing Finance
Authority thank you thank you
representative thank you very much thank
you
sorry
microphone at this point uh you you were
saying when I was finishing writing
about the transfer tax you were saying
something about
dedicating uh that we shouldn't be
dedicating funds somewhere
else yes the the Realtors support the uh
the allocation from the existing real
estate transfer tax to opportunities to
expand housing
we would be concerned if funds from the
real estate transfer tax were used in
another purpose other than expanding
housing and they are already and have
been for quite a long time used by the
education trust
fund and that this specific bill doesn't
deal with the the trust fund so that's
why I was okay phrasing it thank you
representative
alme okay thank you for your testimony
thank
you
next I have
Rob
housing good afternoon Mr chair and
members of the committee thank you very
much for the opportunity to speak I'm
Rob dais I'm the executive director of
New Hampshire housing I'm joined by my
colleague Deputy executive director and
chief legal officer Ben Frost we brought
some fact sheets about the affordable
housing fund as well as a letter in
support of the bill uh which Ben will uh
hand to um the representative there um
for those who aren't familiar with New
Hampshire housing we're a
self-supporting public corporation
created by Statute with a mission to
promote finance and support Housing
Solutions for the people of New
Hampshire so we're a Statewide
independent organization we don't
receive any operating funds from the
state but we run a range of programs uh
which have since our uh establishment in
1981 included uh financing about um
15,000 affordable apartments offering
loans through partner Banks and lenders
to help New Hampshire families achieve
home ownership administering uh the
housing Choice Voucher Program commonly
known as Section 8 for areas of the
state that don't have a local Housing
Authority the same state law that uh was
used to create our organization in 1981
was later used to establish the
affordable housing fund with New
Hampshire housing as it Steward and
administrator and since then the
affordable housing fund has functioned
as a revolving fund and an essential
tool for the creation of affordable
Workforce and Supportive Housing for the
people of the
State uh as uh Carmen mentioned the
governor and legislature have made
historic investments in these last two
banal budgets and we thank you for for
that and for recognizing the housing
issue and for making those Investments
we've used these funds to help create
new housing serving a range of
populations and income
levels uh it's coming online as we uh uh
every every month and so as the info
sheets go around you'll you'll see some
representative projects that we've used
those affordable housing funds for and
as those projects come online they're
improving neighborhoods they're
improving Health outcomes and work
Readiness among New Hampshire residents
and decreasing homelessness and housing
instability we make affordable housing
funds available through two basic
channels uh one is in combination with
the federal housing tax credit that's
the so-called litec that Carmen
mentioned uh and using AHF in
combination with the federal housing
credit uh leveraging of State resources
in the range of 7 to 12 uh federal or
private investment dollars for every
state dollar that's invested um because
the tax credit program is designed to
leave a gap in the financing to require
some commensurate investment at the
state level if we didn't provide that
financing uh certain federal housing
credits and tax against Bond financing
would go
unused uh in addition to that we uh use
affordable housing funds for our
Supportive Housing program
affordable housing funds have fewer
strings attached uh than federal funds
and so they're much more flexible the
support of housing program has been used
uh for housing that serves people with
mental illness developmental
disabilities substance use disorders and
other special needs uh and much of the
small scale housing in New Hampshire
Community serving people in those
populations has been developed with
affordable housing fund
financing all properties financed with
AHF are affordable for at least 20 years
by law uh affordable period of
affordability periods of 30 to 60 years
are also common uh depending on the
other funding sources that are involved
thank you for the opportunity to speak
uh we'd be happy to take any questions
Ames well first off I think it's a great
program um my concern is the dedication
of
money um to this program from the real
estate transfer fund
revenues uh and you have $5 million that
was put in in
2020 um before that you got as I
understand for this fund um
Appropriations were made in the budget
and that was the to the extent to which
the state put money in that was the
source um so in the
budget so we've move from a budget
to um taking from a stream of Revenue an
amount of money and now the proposal is
to double that um and as been as has
been pointed out that stream of money
supports education it goes into the
education trust fund and it's also true
that this
year the and maybe last year I don't
recall the money going into
the uh trust fund from the real estate
transfer tax collections has been going
down um so we're sort of in a bit of a
crunch here education is under the gun
public school funding is under the gun
we're not spending enough that's what
the judge says we're reviewing that
we've just had a couple of bills this
morning that we've been working on
that call for a different way of funding
and more more funding
variously um so we've got that in
play uh and really the question here is
why
not um I think I know the answer but I
might as well ask you why not compete in
the budget process for
funding um as you did to start off uh
rather than then um uh get by Statute an
assured flow of funding that's in
independent of the interplay and the the
tradeoffs that occur in a regular budget
process where you're struggling with
competing priorities for important
projects sure thank you for the question
representative and I think uh the to to
give us a simple answer to a simple
question the uh or the sort of last part
of that question the importance of
having a dedicated
set aside and this is why the
legislature saw fit to make that uh
policy Choice a couple of years ago is
that these projects take years to
develop and during that process
developers are investing hundreds of
thousands of dollars to uh bring
projects forward and it's important for
them to have the predictability of
knowing that there will be a resource on
the other end and prior to the
establishment of the set aside uh that
didn't exist and as a result we saw much
less development of affordable housing
relative to uh neighboring states and
other states of a sort of a similar size
in population and demogra Graphics um $5
million doesn't go as far as it used to
and so uh I think $10 million is what we
see as being necessary sort of um I hate
to put it this way but at a minimum to
provide that kind of predictability in
terms of our ability to continue to
operate a functional housing development
program um if I may just note that
relative to the um I'm not an education
funding policy expert but I believe the
reason that uh has gone down is because
real estate transer tax receipts have
gone down and that's largely a function
of reduced transac transaction activity
because there is so little housing
there's such scarcity on both the rental
side and the for sale side that very few
people are moving because they don't
have someplace to move to so the uh
transfer tax receipts go down and I
think that's why uh Mr Norwood was
testifying earlier on behalf of the
realtors in in favor of this
Bill thank you and that's
helpful representative lley thank thank
you Mr chair um thank you for the
handout I was looking at this online at
the same time I just had a question on
this graphic it says 11
here age restricted 310 units is that a
percent what does 11 mean 11 projects
which comprise 310 units so I'm looking
at this I'm just trying to understand
would it be accurate to say like 10% of
your work is age
restricted projects
uh yes
roughly okay yeah I'm asking because the
last week we discussed Workforce housing
and obviously one of the stipulations of
Workforce housing is that it not be age
restricted and um there's a lot of Need
for Workforce housing and affordable
housing that's not um age restricted so
I just wanted to get a grasp on how much
of of your work um was in that area and
it sounds like it's a small amount
10%
um the other uh question I had relates
to uh your statement that I think is
very helpful to Think Through about you
know the availability of Housing and I
think that the availability of quality
education also impacts the housing
market um I live in
Manchester and when we hire
uh you know a CEO to come in to run
something in Manchester they often
choose not to buy House of
Manchester and I can tell you that
there's one reason for that and it's the
reputation of the education in
Manchester so I would just want to kind
of raise that idea of funding our
education um equitably across the state
also impacts people's housing values um
so I think that these are intertwined
issues that we need to think about and
housing stability is super important um
for children uh getting educated if they
can have a stable place to live that
really helps their ability to learn so I
think it is complex and interrelated and
both deal with the well-being of our our
kids um our Workforce and our older
population so I'm I guess I'm wondering
how how your work plays out across the
state is it um are you involv are these
projects in all over the state are you
geographically more um active in certain
areas can you speak kind kind of walk us
through some of the geography of your
work I'd be happy to thank you for the
question representative and we do work
Statewide and so we have uh properties
of of the uh properties that we've
developed they exist in certainly every
county in the state and and many many
many communities I would say most of the
real estate activity is is going on in
kind of the Southern Tier and in certain
sort of uh hotspots like the Upper
Valley and and uh and around Keane but
um but we do continue to uh work with
Partners uh in The Lakes Region and
north of that and part of that is
Preservation of existing affordable
housing which is an important priority
as well and and affordable housing fund
is very useful for that purpose um but I
think the short answer is we work in
every area of the state areas that more
populists generally see more uh real
estate activity of every sort and that
includes
affordable representative
fellows thank you Mr chair
um so one of the things that we know is
that in
2020 the legislature made a change and
so now you've been receiving $5 million
annually for this affordable housing
fund so that was a big change from what
you had and it's supposed to be it's a
revolving fund so a lot of it is loans
but you know you give the money out and
the payments are coming back in what how
has this affected the balance of that
fund you know
regard where where we are right now so
we're considering what we might want to
make a change but right now H how is
that impacting your available funds to
give out every year sure thank you for
the question representative and and so
uh the the funds that have been
allocated and received to date have
essentially been fully reserved to
projects and just to explain how we
structure it when we put a loan into a
project so that it can uh charge
affordable rents and and instead of the
sort of market rate of say $2,000 to
$2,500 a month U rent for something
that's uh you know perhaps $1,100 or
something that's affordable for somebody
making 60% of the area median income we
structure that debt as a second loan uh
in second position in terms of its its
mortgage position and no it's it's not
like a home mortgage you don't need to
make principal and interest payments
every month uh we do uh structure it so
that if the project cash flows if uh if
everybody's paying their rent and and
they're able to pull pay the full rent
sometimes a little bit will come back we
take 50% of the Project's cash flow uh
each year um but to answer your question
about what that means in terms of our we
revolving yet like it has a lot of that
money come back and are we able to
redeploy it um the answer is no because
generally affordable housing projects
indeed we underwrite them to just barely
break even so that we're not putting in
any more public dollars than is
necessary they're servicing their debt
uh you know these last couple of years
have been a rocky ride as you can
imagine between utility costs Insurance
costs have gone up substantially and so
that I think speaks to the impact of the
affordable housing fund because those
second mortgages that we put in with AHF
do not require monthly payments those
projects are able to maintain their
economic stability and and still take
care of the facilities uh and and be
nice places to live is that was that
clear enough representative did that
make
sense so that was very
enlightening so now my question is it
doesn't really sound like a revolving
fund so it sounds like most of the money
is just I don't know what to I I would
call it grants I think you probably
subsidies maybe is a better word so
you're subsidizing it and it's not
really meant to be a pot of money that
that grows and can be reused is that or
most of it is in that category it's more
like an appropriation that you can give
out to
subsidize the existence
of subsidized housing I think that's a
fair point representative in most ways
it behaves like a subsid I mean I think
it's it's different in that if a
property were sold at the end of the
affordability period all that money
would come back to the affordable
housing fund uh and and there are
occasionally projects that cash flow and
and we do receive that money back we
don't take any admin off it we put it
right back into other projects it's just
not a substantial amount that would
allow us to kind of you know do a new
project every two years for for each
project that we Finance or something
like
that uh representative elme did you have
a followup uh no follow up on a question
not a followup but actually it's
followup to something quite a bit ago
but on in the bad old days when you were
getting a million dollars a year out of
the
legislature
on FR from the budget
on the you were also as I recall doing a
lot of age
related um age
limited on projects because that was all
that the towns were willing to allow to
go
up and um how many of these
11 restricted age restricted units are
from before the time when when you
money I don't know we can find out the
answer to that representative uh I I
don't know how many of the 11 a district
projects we financed with AHF are from
uh the old days we still do a little bit
of age restricted housing but it's true
that um you know I guess I would say
also needed but maybe not quite as
urgently
as as the
youth right and I go ahead Ben one thing
I would add representative Aly is um
you're you're very generous in in your
characterization of uh the the earlier
Appropriations uh in fact they didn't
get to a million sometimes they did not
get to a million sometimes in fact u a
number of years many years most years
they were zero it was 5 million once
ited 2001 I believe it started with an
appropriation in 1988 of $4 million the
next appropriation was in 2002 and that
was $5 million uh over the first 30
years of the affordable housing funds
existence uh the legislature made
appropriations of of $22.6 million which
over time really is not a whole lot of
money it's only with uh the recent
onetime Appropriations made by the
legislature and the
ongoing uh transfer tax uh uh allocation
that we've seen more substantial
Appropriations that has allowed us to do
more all right uh yes I'm going to take
one more question represent Alberta
thank you Mr chairman um I live in ashaa
and drive past the Monahan man projects
it was really fun watching the old
buildings come down and the new ones
come up and then starting to be
repopulated so thanks um I'm wondering
if you know about funds available
through the federal GAO and
transportation department to be used
for
redeveloping no longer being used
Federal property
and whether you've done any work
out we've had this uh conversation
before I think about a month ago uh and
uh we we've not historically done that
but we will be looking into it okay
thank you thank you thank you both thank
you okay um next I'm going to invite
Alyssa marolia
[Music]
up
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is
Alyssa margolin I serve as director of
housing action New Hampshire we are a
Statewide Coalition of 80 organizations
United to improve state and federal
policy so everyone in New Hampshire has
a place to call home our members are
those who develop Finance manage and
support affordable housing properties
support of housing properties homeless
service agencies public housing agencies
and low-income family advocates
um I won't repeat uh prior testimony I
will um underscore that the housing
crisis has been identified in at least
three recent polls as the number one
issues number one issue facing Granite
Staters um I think uh I've been doing
this now since 2009 I think that that's
because the housing crisis is now now
impacting everyone um we have Workforce
shortages in every sector including
essential services disincentives for
business growth barriers for young
families to call New Hampshire home
challenges for housing choice for
retirees and debilitating Financial
impacts on lower income families um and
so um I'm going to connect that now to
the history of the affordable housing
fund um in the late 80s uh when uh the
public private partnership uh gained
momentum as a solution and using
financing tools uh to develop affordable
housing these trust funds were created
in every state unfortunately New
Hampshire was one of uh I believe only
three states that did not dedicate a
funding source for its trust fund and so
we at housing action New Hampshire um
really were formed in a way to change
that here um the uh Most states fund
their trust funds with a fee additional
fee on real estate
transactions that was not a viable
solution in the state um and so years
and years we worked with our friends the
Realtors and a lot of thoughtful
legislators to identify a different
approach a different New Hampshire
approach and that big agreement came
around in 2020 that you've identified
and that was a car out approach this
idea that the market when left on its
own is developing this revenue for the
state but that it this Market when left
on its own is not building affordable
options that diverse housing stock and
it is creating not only extreme pressure
on very low-income families but also you
know a a gap in our Workforce and all
the other things I just identified so
this solution of the car out um uh
started as you note and um the feedback
back from membership from our members is
we need more predictability in that
process like 5 million wasn't enough to
get the attention of a lot of developers
who are going to be putting in
substantial amount of you know
preconstruction Investments so uh New
Hampshire need to step up and then we
had those discussions and got to this
agreement um and so I hope that you'll
uh consider that because this has been
in discussion for a long time and I'll
also note that the bill was amended in
the Senate so that this would start uh
in the next bium so it is not impacting
this budget and I'll conclude my
testimony um and I'd be happy to take
any
questions seeing none thank you very
much um Keane I have a question for you
do you know the breakdown from the real
estate transfer
tax how it's
distributed if so please come
forward
good afternoon Representatives my name
is Keen mayong tax policy council with
in New Hampshire
Dr good afternoon my name is Lauren O
Sullivan senior Financial Analyst at the
Dr and if you give me just one quick
moment I'll calculate the education
trust fund transfer eyeballing it it
looks like it might be a third but let
that yeah it's uh 33% of the real estate
transfer tax goes to the education trust
fund and the remainder is in the um
general
fund okay anybody have any question yes
repres well I thought we were just told
that since 2020 that 5 million of it was
going to this affordable housing
so the uh the cash plan that I'm working
off of takes into account the 5 million
going to the affordable housing fund is
there any other follow up is there any
else um there is the lchip program so
that plan I I believe that does not
include the lchip either that program do
you I mean the budget plan sorry not
program do you have those
figures I do not have the lchip St
that's with
me if you could and that that's um and
that's a function of the r that month is
um what would go to lchip and that is um
that is um remitted separately so
there's the r and then there's the lchip
portion they're two separate things okay
if is it possible to send us send the
committee the breakdown of the real
estate transfer tax on sure work
absolutely okay thank you representative
Ames
I'm sure we'll get it when you send that
and we do get it regularly but can you
update us on the uh R uh revenues for
this fiscal year actually I so I have um
through February so year to date um we
are we are at $131 million
collected um and the plan is
year to date so we are uh 20.7 million
below plan at the moment but that plan
would would go or the year ends what
June 30th June 30th so it seems like
it's tracking in a way that it should be
so it's just the first half of the year
has been very weak we're just coming I
think um what it's starting to look like
looking at the growth rate of
transactions from January and February
and a little bit of December that we're
starting to finally see some growth in
terms of
transactions um so we're hoping that in
the back half we might be able to make
up some ground but that's to be seen
right it's it's still we're nowhere near
the um highs that we saw in fiscal year
21 which was peak in terms of
transactions and what was holding the
tax up was that even though the
transactions were going down the medium
the medium price had remained pretty
high and it was really the end of last f
year and the first half of this fiscal
year we're starting to see where the
median couldn't support um any further
growth in the red thank
you any other questions seeing none
thank you oh I'm sorry represent spsb
just gonna um do you happen to have with
you uh what was the r collections
year-to date last year and the year
before and the plan for
those because I I know our Revenue
projections uh were decreased
substantially for R yes so last year
year to date was aund um and this is
both when I'm speaking it's the general
fund and the education trust fund
together so last year year to date was
159.000 compared to the 131.8 million
this year and the year before
that H I'd have to calculate
unfortunately I only have the individual
months not the sum of that so
well you want to give me a moment I can
pull I can calculate it I have it just
not
summed while she's calculating that is
there anyone else after this that would
want to speak on
sb4
way
it was
151.50 Million at at this point in
fiscal year 22 and that does not include
the affordable housing transfer because
that all occurs at the end of September
so we've already seen that money leave
the
fund okay any fur other
questions seeing none thank you very
much okay I'm going to close the public
okay we'll open I'm going to open the
you so I'll need U you'll just have
okay
okay uh good morning chairman members of
the uh house Ways and Means Committee uh
happy to be back in this room after
serving three terms in it when I was in
the house I very much like this room um
so this bill that you have before you
cleans up a process that happens to
unclaim horse racing and unclaimed horse
racing tickets and at the same time
supports the governor scholarship fund
which is for our New Hampshire graduates
um here in New Hampshire attending
attending New Hampshire colleges um most
unclaimed monies go to the state treasur
and then held for an additional 24 month
mons if no one claims the money it's
finally rotated into the general fund
unclaimed gaming money ALS also goes to
treasure but with historic horse racing
in particular um there's no way to
identify who receives the prize because
it's just a little slip you get when you
place the BET um it's not tied to an
individual um uh and but the players
would then take that slip and go up and
cash out with the at the at the um
machine occasionally people don't cash
them out and that money just kind of
hangs out on the books of the gaming
operators um until such point it's 24
months old and then they submit it to
the treasurer's office would then hold
it for another 24 months and then it
would finally hit the general register
this bill seeks to fix that delay and
that problem um this bill states that on
July One chedle gaming operators must
total up the unclaimed horse racing and
historic horse racing money for the
previous calendar year and write a check
to the treasurer and then that money
will be deposited directly into um the
governor's scholarship fund um as I call
your attention to the bill I'm going to
ask you to make some corrections there
are two mistakes in the bill um that I
caught after um it passed the Senate um
so on line four of the introduced Bill
you'll see it it crosses out or historic
horse racing you need to add that back
in um there was a discussion and I don't
remember getting a committee vote but
that's okay it somehow ended up in the
bill and over here and then on line 14
we have an undefined term historic horse
racing gaming operators or or horse
racing gaming operators we don't have
that defined anywhere in statute it
should be the same thing that's on line
three it should be any person
Association or Corporation shall submit
what line 14 so line 14 it says on July
one of every year historic racing game
operators there's no definition of that
anywhere in the statute what it really
should say is um any person uh
Association or
Corporation and then that'll correct the
two errors that are on this
bill as it comes to revenue um what this
bill means is that currently it's about
200,000 for horse racing that are
unclaimed monies that would go annually
to the general fund um here we're adding
the new the historic horse racing which
hasn't hit a reporting date yet we're
adding that in so it'll be about 400
Grand a year would go into the governor
scholarship fund to support New
Hampshire students attending New
Hampshire colleges for scholarships if
you don't know how that scholarship
works you have to be a firsttime student
um attending in in a an a Hampshire
graduate and you're able to apply um it
pays full tuition doesn't play room
aboard but it play up to 100% of tuition
for uh someone going to UNH Plymouth
State Keen State Granite well I don't
know if Granite State still exists um
but any of the New Hampshire University
system colleges I'm happy to take
questions represent
Aly thank you uh my first question is
can you explain to me the pro what role
a voucher and a ticket play in historic
horse racing sure absolutely so when you
when you play and you put your money
into the machine and you play the
machine and at the end you end up with a
total that's left over so say I put 20
bucks in I end up losing 18 of it right
and I have $2 left when you're done you
hit your cash out and you get a little
slip for $2 which you would then have to
take to the cash cage and turn that in
for $2 a lot of people don't do that um
if it's not worth the effort for a $2
ticket they won't bother to do it um
I'll give you an example I have a I have
a sports betting ticket that I did the
day sports betting opened here in New
Hampshire and I still haven't cashed it
in that was in
2019 um so it's not uncommon if you only
win a little bit of money that you may
not go cash that voucher in but on the
end it's 200 Grand in aggregate across
the state and rather than having the
operators have them sit on that
liability for two years and then turn
that liability to the state who then
sits on that liability for two years
instead what we're saying is the
operators will sit on it for one year
and then on July 1st of every year
they'll submit a report to the to the
Lottery Commission saying here's all the
tickets here's the total amount of money
and here's a check for that total amount
of money um and then Lottery could then
deposit those funds into the governor
scholarship
fund I had a follow question and I still
don't understand is that a voucher they
call I think they call it a voucher it's
a slip of M it's a ticket that they get
from the machine that's printed I'm not
sure exactly what the title is words
yeah I'm sorry they're equivalent words
ticket andou yeah ticket and voucher
same thing they get a ticket from the
machine or voucher from the machine that
says this is basically your winnings it
could be you know you could have 23
cents left or you could have more money
than that and and the other qu the the
pro real question was on the fiscal note
says that this four of this
400,000 200,000 of it is going to the
governor's scholarship fund and 200 of
it is going to the horse R historic
horse racing
operators so again that's because of the
amended compens because we have the
mistake in there once she fix that
mistake all $400,000 go to the the
governor scholarship fund when you fix
those two errors adding back historic
horse racing and changing that language
onine 14 we'll need to there's
someone John yeah I'm sure John will be
happy to Mr be happy to speak
representative PL yes if you were rever
clerk you wouldn't speak as fast as you
do repeat slowly the two in all fairness
I was the clerk of ways and means my
first ter in the house oh okay repeat
slowly the two fixes please the two
fixes are on page on on line four add
back in where says or historic horse
racing so put that line that struck out
put it back
in okay line four and then on line
sorry okay and then on line 14 there's
an undefined term where it says horse
racing gaming operators need to strike
that and replace it with um
any person Association or Corporation
Association that's a word I was missing
now a follow on question Mr chair Y what
is the governor scholarship fund so the
governor scholarship fund was created I
think in 2020 I don't remember exactly
when it was created it might have been
2018 or 19 um and the governor
scholarship fund is a a college
scholarship fund for the Hampshire
graduates and it's for firsttime
students um to pay their wish to attend
College whether it's public or private I
believe in New Hampshire representative
Bolton so U thank you Mr chair so I was
just wondering how long is that voucher
good for can you cash in your 2019
voucher or is it dead when you leave the
well so because of our statute which is
a two-year cycle my money's dead is gone
um because every two years unclaimed
money unclaimed properties are turned
back into the Secretary of State um so
that voucher is no good under this stat
you the the uh gaming operators would
wouldn't would let people know that you
have 12 months to collect your money
after that it's gone okay all
Ames I'm checking myself here am I right
in thinking that if you or if we um
amended
out the sentence that
sends sends the money to the governor's
scholarship fund if we deleted that
sentence that the uh the result then
would be that the the money would flow
into the ETF the education trust fund
this Lottery
revenues I honestly don't know the
answer to that question Lottery May
answer be able to answer that uh it may
go to the education trust fund um it's a
weird depends on the definition of
gaming stuff so we'll check
unfortunately yeah so um behind you
again our goal was we know that you know
we've heard the story all along about
student debt right and so this is a way
of of helping the Hampshire students get
a leg up in in their in their work is by
supporting that fund and allowing for
tuition to be paid then that's that much
less in student debt they'll have when
they come out of college I'll just in
response I'll just say that I totally
agree that's a real need so is the uh
need to meet the OB obligations to
public schools so we've got as with the
lots of things we do lots of needs and
limited money just I'm just not sure
because it's unclaimed money where that
money would end up because our statute
for unclaimed money is completely
different than everything else yeah and
so right now all unclaimed money goes to
the general fund so if it falls under
that process it goes to the general fund
so I don't know that it would ever make
it to the education trust fund we'll
find out that's a
probably question
follows um I'm just trying to follow the
um track of what happens so I I think
that the um the
operator looks at um when he gets to the
end of our one of our bium which is the
end of June that's when they figure out
the tickets that were unclaimed and they
send them to the state and the state
hangs on to them for about a year and if
nobody makes a claim on them then that's
when it goes into the fund is that
correct so it's if I'm not mistaken it's
two years and two years so it be a total
of four years before the money would hit
the general oh because it's is it the
operator holds it for two years and then
the by our unclaimed money statutes
another 24 months I believe you have to
hold the treasurer has to hold it on top
of once it receives it it then and be
honestly it also means that the
treasurer has to advertise I don't know
how you adverti for a 23 Cent ticket you
know voucher
and how much money that costs to to for
advertising because like now they would
have to quantify all of that on their
website the goal was to make it
streamline the treasures office and
streamline this process and support our
college students so our grades follow up
so um is the first sentence the one
that's on line three that says on or
before July 31
I how does it how does that relate to
the July one so I think it's to allow
them that so on July 1
um that's a good question I don't know
the answer to that sorry maybe John can
answer that we may have to change that
January one to July one as well they
both say submit money yeah to so I think
it was the intention was to have it be
say
okay that may need
investigation where was elme do you have
question or
sorry and I'll be happy to put together
a basic Amendment for you so you don't
get I hate bringing a bill in and make
somebody do my work so I don't mind
doing the works it's my fault one of us
will have the sponsor be happy to if you
do the work okay actually that's
that I think when it goes house to
Senate it does because when I submit it
has to be a House member that supports
yeah
okay before house ways and means it's a
house bill
now okay thank you
Senator um who did you want to hear from
John
coni uh could John coni please come
he
yeah
yeah I don't have
a you'll have to just fill out a pink
card later John and I I will I apologize
I did not intend on uh no that's having
to testify we do have card for Valerie
so uh once again uh good afternoon John
Cony Chief compliance officer for the
New Hampshire
Lottery and Valerie King also with New
Hampshire
lottery so I think I can answer a couple
of the questions that came up um with
respect to to this um uh we can work
with uh Senator uh Lang and
representative PL you're correct that uh
we're trying to uh we're trying to
correct a an already confusing process
in statute and I think we have
conflicting dates in there so um we'll
work with Senator Lang uh to make sure
that we get some clarification on that
January 31 date so that it all flows
together in one way um with respect to
the funds um there is a it's stated in
the law that the These funds do flow
into R 284 21j from the um Treasurer's
Office 28421 J I believe if I'm not
mistaken is uh the Lottery Commission
fund which then flows into the education
trust fund after um after our expenses
are paid um so that money that is the
the uh I can confirm that for you
representative Ames but I believe that's
flows follow I'm not sure I understood
that you're saying that
currently
the equivalent of what's described here
is flowing into the education trust fund
it is and just currently historic course
racing has not met uh as Senator Lang
indicated there's a long lag time for
unclaimed funds so we haven't actually
had historic horse racing unclaimed
funds uh come through yet um but
currently for horse racing simal cast uh
racing um those unclaimed monies get
dist get uh paid to the treasurer's
office any claims that come in they get
paid out of that and anything that's
left over is uh is part of the special
fund under RC 28421 J that is the
lottery commissions fund that then um
then funds education the education trust
fund after our expenses are paid yeah so
sure the Constitutional provision
requires
that Lottery revenues from the state run
Lottery which I presume includes what
we're talking about here um must go to
uh be used exclusively for the purpose
of State a to
education um and also refers to the
school districts of the state so I'm
wondering whether you can actually do
this so representative Ames I I that's a
complicated legal question I do I would
just flag for you that uh traditionally
Lottery and racing were separate uh
commissions um and so um the restriction
on lottery funds um I believe make carry
only with the lottery games um whereas
the gaming which is now overseen by um
by The Lottery Commission uh I'm not
sure if that's subject to the same uh
constitutional restriction we would have
to check with the Department of Justice
to confirm that aren't you advertising
that your Reven revenues are going into
education we do
yes um well I I urge that you ask that
you and perhaps we should independently
ask
for advice on this from the attorney
general because there may be a
constitutional
conflict we can do that represent
Ames
okay representative two questions now on
one I take it that if the racing is
considered separate for this purpose we
would have to take the sentence on lines
text um not I I don't know necessarily
whether that would have to be removed
again there have been other payments
that have been made out of that fund
that have not been specific uh to um
that have been considered expenses of
the commission
um so the the distribution to the
governor's um the governor scholarship
fund may be considered a expense to the
commission as
well um that's been done with Kino funds
that were um that were um set aside for
past
the it was much more closely
linked
uh my other question is this one about
tickets and vouchers which appear in the
existing language as well as in the new
language
and what is the difference between a
ticket and a voucher a ticket is the
original betting ticket that one gets um
so if you are going to uh bet on the
Kentucky Derby when you put your um bet
in you would get a ticket back that
would um say what your bet is um a
voucher is as Senator Lang indicated a
um uh is money owed to you uh usually
from a machine um that comes out so for
example with historic course racing
there are no real tickets they are all
vouchers um you would put your $20 or
$10 into a machine you play um and then
when you're done playing you cash out
and what you cash out is a is a is a
voucher um so that's payable um upon um
upon presentation uh at the facility at
either an a different machine or with
your with the
much I have no more pink cards um is
there anyone else who would like to tell
by on SB
473 seeing none I'll close the public
473 okay we'll now open the public
hearing on S SP
497 and
recognize Grant
BOS
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee and thank you Senator Lang for
filling in for me I'm Grant bossy uh
here to introduce Senate Bill 361 on
behalf of Senator Bradley the Bill's
Prime sponsor sp sp 497 FN creates a
non-aps dedicated account for the
disperate share hospital or dish fund
having a separate account will allow the
Department of Health and Human Services
to distribute the funds more efficiently
the Senators uh excuse me the C for
Medicare and Medicaid services require
that the share exam be completed each
fiscal year to determine the amount of
dish money for each Hospital excess
funds are redistributed to the hospitals
in a manner laid out by the State
Medicaid plan the dish fund would only
receive dish payments from the hospitals
and will only pay out funds to the
hospitals making the process cost
neutral to the state if you have any
questions for Senator Bradley I will try
to get you an answer uh thank you again
for allowing me to bring in this bill
for Senator Brenton thank you
representative
elmy thank you I have never heard the
word examinations used in quite this way
before and presumably it is um an a
fiscal audit of the
hospitals
and given that on what's the flow of the
money the it sounds like maybe
the hospitals are requested to provide
money for these examinations that goes
into this fund and then they figure out
how much each Hospital owes or is owed
and distribute the money that way but it
doesn't go through this fund is that
what we're looking at rather than me
going from memory on the history of the
me in the dish I would recommend uh
asking that of the Department of Health
and Human Services and is are you they
are coming okay good because my
understanding of these things is about
examinations representative PL I have no
idea what we're talking about what's a
disproportionate share again I think I
think the department will be be able to
better address uh this program it's it's
designed uh to help uh New Hampshire
hospitals uh that need a little more
help in providing care to New
Hampshire's most needy populations I
would defer the department to walk you
through the entire dish program sounds
for okay so we will therefore invite up
Robert Barry from New Hampshire DHHS who
can hopefully clarify some of these
questions
so um for the record Robert Barry um
general counsel to the division of
Medicaid uh for the New Hampshire
Department of Health and Human Services
um the dish program is um if you wanted
to have a full picture of it it would
take probably four or five hours and
three or four more people than me uh to
go through it but this is a really
simple Bill uh what I can I'll give you
the the general flow of how dish works
and hopefully that'll alleviate um any
concerns or questions about this but
essentially um dish is paid out uh for
uh hospitals what they're what's called
uncompensated care uh and this is for uh
hospitals that serve uh uninsured
individuals or a large number of
Medicaid individuals it's um it's funds
that flow to it uh to each Hospital uh
in May of every year and it's paid uh
for through the um Medicaid enhancement
tax um so the initial Dish payment what
we call the interm payment um is paid
out uh in one year we'll say 2020 for
instance then there is a dish
examination that occurs three years
later and representative all me you're
right it's uh it's a financial audit um
each Hospital submits their um their
uncompensated care uh cop cost for the
year in question to our external uh
auditing entity Myers and staer uh and
they determine what the actual
uncompensated care was for the hospital
for that given year um that usually
happens uh 3 years after the initial
payment is done so um in 2023 we just
got the results of 2020 this year we'll
just get we'll get 2021 so when that
happens when we get those results back
we have to reconcile the amounts that
were paid paid so it's a finite pool of
money but some hospitals will have to
pay into the fund and other hospitals
will receive the funds from the
hospitals that are payers so there will
be payers and receivers in the end the
state ends up in a net zero balance uh
but it's just a way to redistribute the
funds and what this serves to do is to
make it uh efficient and um and uh easy
for the Department to administer this
redistribution process which we're
obligated to do under federal law
okay thank
you
Ames it uh my understanding of this is
that this is an important um provision
that is needed the powers that that be
or the knowledgeable people say and I
take that as gospel and uh that passing
this will enable uh sort of seamlessly
the process to continue yes you're
correct representative uh this was
Department requested legislation um so
uh we're grateful to the senator for uh
sponsoring this bill uh we felt it was
very important uh from a uh a process
standpoint to accomplish what we have to
federally
do yes representative Bolton thank you
thank you Mr chair so um we have a
couple of for-profit hospitals in New
Hampshire do they qualify for for Dish
as well
or definitely I believe every hospital
qualifies yeah I we we pay out to around
24 right now um I don't know what the
full number of hospitals in New
Hampshire is but I think they're 26
actually it might be 20 it's in that
that uh that range I count them up
occasionally and then I forget the
number but uh it's in the 20s okay I
think I answer thank you
yes R and Ali yes um this part I don't
remember at all on they get a prepayment
three years before three years before
they need to
it we didn't start by giving them money
for three
years how did this thing work out to the
point where where does where did the
money that started this so you want to
go back to
200 I guess fiveish when we got rid of
um Medicaid
um on the scam game that we were
playing
uh we were getting double back from from
the feds and they finally decided they
didn't want to do that anymore
um of what the um Hospital Aid
was
and and I guess we might have started
with with some of that money because I
remember it was painful but not that
painful I think you're getting into some
history that I may not be aware of I've
been uh involved in the dish program for
about 2 years now and
um and like I said it it there's a team
of people uh when I say there's a dish
team there is a team of people and also
involves many outside Consultants uh so
to the extent this history goes back
much further than than that I'm probably
not going to be directly aware of it but
to my knowledge um we've been paying the
interim payments with uh met revenue for
at least a decade probably more than
that that um and we base the interim
payment on uncompensated care from two
years prior to the the the date in
question so this year we're doing 24
payments will be based on 22 data um and
then it'll in three years they'll be
audited so the numbers are never going
to quite match up um but that's how we
um
representative fellows thank you Mr
chair so you've got two different you
have one existing fund already the the
338 and you want to create a new
one
correct
yes oh so my of section one is it's
creating a new it's making a reference
to the paragraph one the new paragraph
one
sorry maybe that part doesn't matter so
my my question is I I think you have one
one um fund now and you want two funds
is that because one is for the money
that flows in from
Medicaid and the other one is for money
going out to the hospitals so one in I'm
not fully sure about this but one might
be just for the receipt of the Met
Revenue I don't know that for a fact but
that that could be one and then the
second one is just for the
redistribution process so that's money
we receive from the
hospitals uh the paying hospitals and
then we turn around and immediately push
it out to the receiving hospitals for um
um for the redistribution process so
there's two different processes going on
here the redistribution process is not
process representative PL oh I'm sorry
follow yeah so my point being
was it may make sure that the titles
make it clear what what that fund is for
because um representative Al May and I
just were looking at another
Department's fund funds and we couldn't
tell by the title what they were so that
it it looks
like maybe if you put the
word it says deposited but you're
telling me it's redistribution maybe you
should use the word redistribution
online if that's an in and out account
because it says deposit so what I'll do
is I'll go back and check with the
finance folks because they're the ones
that helped out with this legislation I
I'm not a finance wizard um I'm just a
mere
attorney representative PL I'm sorry and
then represent me yes you used an acrom
dish yes I want to make certain I
understand what the acronym stands or is
it disproportionate Hospital
disproportionate share Hospital okay and
not Department of Health and Human
Services no that's the
HHS representative
eling thank you um I
found f on section three
confusing on in that it was
clear that it was going
to take all disproportionate Hospital
share hospital um Revenue received to be
credited to the
then it talked about this
disproportionate share
examinations on and the fiscal note
seemed to talk about using this fund to
pay for these
examinations no it doesn't pay for the
examinations um it's a result of the
findings of an examin
and the reason why we use the term
examination because that's the federal
language um but it does equate to an
audit okay so this fund is really just
the monies that came in from Medicaid
for the
hospitals and the money that the
hospitals sent
back to the state it's the money they
sent yeah it's the money they sent back
as a result of the findings of the
examination and then we take that uh
those funds and then we have to
redistribute it out to uh hospitals that
were not uh paid as much as they should
have been so it's a zero some game in
that sense that nothing remains in in
the fund it all goes right back out and
and somewhere
in in the statutes there is something
that explains how the examinations were
done and paid
for it I don't know if it goes into That
explicit of detail but the examinations
are required by federal law um so uh not
done by federal law what but they are
not done by the feds no no it's done by
an independent uh entity Myers and staer
uh we we have to pay for them yes so we
pay for them um and we're required to
have an independent entity do it so um
every year we work with Myers and
staford to provide them with the
information they request of us they
reach out to the hospitals individually
and then come December of every year uh
they provide us the results of the um of
the examination going back three years
CMS interes yeah
um I'm wondering if um the languages
needs to be tweaked in in at line
[Music]
15 um
where the sentence is saying that the
money and the fund is there for the
purpose of redistributing
disproportionate share Hospital funds
between and among hospitals and then it
says for completion of the federally
required disproportionate share Hospital
examinations does that mean in
compliance with instead it for
completion of is confusing language okay
yeah so it's to effectuate what the feds
require which is for us to redistribute
the the funds in accordance with our
state plan after an examination has been
uh completed um maybe you could check on
that and if if better wording like what
I suggested in compliance with sure
would better effectuate the purpose and
make it clearer okay um then it's easily
changed at this point in the game it
won't be easily changed much later no
clear anything else one more do you know
what's happening right now is it are is
it all going in and out of one fund the
one we had to get a fund established
through the fiscal committee and my
understanding is we have to do that
every year which is why we're hoping to
do it through the statute to to make it
a little bit more efficient right now
we're in the process of of
redistributing um for years 11 through
17 and uh we um we've just completed our
second payments uh for that so we had a
a quarterly um redistribution collection
and then as soon as we collect from the
owing hospitals we send it right back
out to the uh receiving hospitals so we
held on to the money for I think a week
tops okay thank you very
much I have no more pink cards for SB
497 is there anyone else who would like
to testify on HB SB
497 seeing none we'll close the public
hearing almost
there timberx somewhat
complicated okay next I will open the
public hearing on SB 513 and recognize
Grant
bossy thank you again Mr chairman
members of the committee I remain Grant
bossy here to
introduce um Senate Bill 513 on behalf
of Senator Ganon the prime sponsor this
bill would permit charity auctions by
nonprofit corporations Senator Ganon not
being an expert on auctions called in a
ringer to help him and that's former
Senator Harold French uh Senator French
volunteers for charitable organizations
to conduct auctions and he explained to
Senator Ganon that he as the auctioneer
has no control over the items or the ad
advertising no custody of the money or
proceeds he just does the job as an
Auctioneer this bill would allow a
nonprofit corporation to conduct an
auction using an Auctioneer like Senator
French this bill would make the code
easier than it is presently in committee
Senator Rosenwald offered a friendly
amendment to clarify that there must be
a charitable purpose for such an auction
uh if you have any questions for Senator
Ganon I'd be happy to get you an answer
uh since this bill passed the Senate we
did receive an email from uh Michael
Haley he's the acting director of the
charitable trust unit he has a concern
with the current
language um in the bill uh the
definition of a charitable organization
as eligible under RSA 7 uh
212b uh would currently exclude
religious organizations that was not the
intent of the bill so there may need to
be a tweak to the language to include
all sorts of charitable organizations
including religious ones uh if you have
a question on that or would like some
help getting that language together I'm
sure Senator Ganon would be happy to
help you again I am not an expert on
this bill but if you have questions I
can get them to Senator Ganon or I can
defer to some other people uh preferably
with the Department okay thank you
representative omy followed by
representative
fellows yes on could we get in Michael
Haley of the charitable
Trust
to discuss this since it's his concern
and this is a very confusing part of
Statute that we were going to clean up
about five six years ago and nobody I
guess the person who was most concerned
didn't run again or
something that is uh all of the
Charities that aren't
c3s
but that are listed in another section
of our Charities as being okay yeah this
this bill deals with auctioneers and
then by reference it gets into that
Thicket of non for-profit organizations
and I think uh the reference was not
been represented
fellow thank you I I'm just wondering if
this is something that actually belongs
bels under the Licensing Laws because I
believe an Auctioneer has to be
licensed and if that's the case then
maybe it would be in there that you that
you would put an
exception for a
charity I think the idea was not to uh
again I can look into this a little
further but the idea wasn't to alter the
auctioneer's license you would still be
a licensed auctioneer but the current
RSA um basically makes the auctioneer
responsible for the goods being off
auctioned and in these charity auctions
the auctioneer doesn't own doesn't
control doesn't have anything to do
they're just providing the service of
the transaction itself so they didn't
think it would be appropriate for the
auctioneer to face the same liability
for the products as if say they're
auctioning off their own thing their
their own products or holding their own
auction
auction they would still have to be a
licensed auction here to perform the
service yeah follow up yeah my my if I'm
wondering if whoever got put this bill
together had some kind of conversation
with Edna I just didn't want to put
something in you know if there's
licensing Auctioneer licensing statutes
in one RSA I didn't want to put
something that contradicts that in a
different
RSA
okay representative
almond there is uh put your microphone
on please yeah on
311b um there's a state board of
auctioneers you'd think that they would
have been pulled into
oplc
um it's a fairly long
statute
through Rob
Senator yes I'm referring
to lines nine and 10 the auctioner shall
not receive any commission from sales or
a percentage of the revenues as
compensation is did you expect the
auction to do it for nothing or is there
flat fee possible or what yeah it'd be a
fee for service rather than a cut of the
proceeds therefore they wouldn't be
responsible for the items being
auctioned themselves they'd just be
performing the service of an Auctioneer
to to run the auction in a a competent
and trustworthy manner uh without the
same liability that we put on them for
stuff representative just an update on
Section
B3 does on say that they need the
approval of the executive director of
The Office of profession professional
licens and certification so presumably
oplc
representative so I have a question for
you do you think that this bill was
us um I don't make that determination
the speaker sent it into us okay but I
might say it's about
charitable
gaming in a way the the bill as as
passed by the Senate doesn't adjust
anything to do with the auctioneer
license auctioneers would still have the
same responsibilities this would allow a
charitable organization to contract out
for an Auctioneer without to to allow
the auctioneer as representative CL said
to do a fee for service rather than
basically run the whole auction and be
financially responsible for the whole
thing follow yes so that's exactly my
concern because we have for somebody to
be called an
Auctioneer I I to me it means that they
have a license to be an Auctioneer and I
I believe you would still need to be a
properly licensed Auctioneer in the
state of New Hampshire to perform this
service they couldn't just have me do
it but it line five says without a
license I'm not sure for that
organization yeah the the organization
would not need to be have an auction
license they could hire a licensed
Auctioneer to come in and perform that
service but it wouldn't be removing them
from
oplc it's more of a liability Bill than
it is a li a change to the
license representative
lle thank you Mr
chair I don't understand the need for
this
legislation can well I guess the
question is is there a need for this
legl yes that's my question can you help
me understand why we need this
legislation is it fixing a problem in
statute is it fixing I
I'm currently a charitable organization
to bring in an Auctioneer to hire them
to say we'll pay you this fee to conduct
our auction no matter how much we raise
um you can do that but then the current
statute then makes that Auctioneer who's
just coming in for the day to pound the
gavel and speak quickly and get get all
the in would have the same liability
for everything that church charity
nonprofit organization is auctioning the
auctioneer would be personally liable
for everything that's going on there and
that that that makes those auctioneers
reluctant to do it it makes it harder
for the Charities uh Senator French felt
that this would be a good way to fix
it and that's the way it works now when
an Auctioneer auctions properties off
they're liable for everything yeah yeah
there there's there's much
steeper um liabilities because they're
cond they're licensed by the state to
conduct things in a certain way and if
there's any sort of fraud or deception
or anything like that obviously that's a
violation of what they've agreed to do
as a
elberger thank you Mr chairman I tend to
read
lines 3 to five as representative
fellows does I think I think I'm
agreeing with you um
that particularly on line five it says
that non-member individuals hired can
Pro engage in auctioning services for
charity auctions without a license to me
that phrase without a license doesn't
refer to the organization it refers to
that represent I don't see how this
language in front of us addresses at all
the uh auctioneers uh not having
responsibility because it doesn't say
that
anywhere uh so point out where you know
how it removes the auctioneer from any
uh obligation the auctioneer would
otherwise have because it doesn't say
anything towards that let me see if we
can get some people before you they can
answer tell me your questions uh and
furthermore shouldn't it say that the
when it says the auctioner shall not
receive any commission from sales or
percentage of the revenues this
compensation shouldn't also say but a
fee for service may be rendered or
something like that uh you you could do
that if if something isn't prohibited by
law it's allowed okay so but you could
that represent elberger um
line uh the contract for auctioneering
services shall be in writing that's line
five to six and then starting on line
eight the contract shall State the
auctioneers duties and compensation if
any whether monetary or otherwise so
this does account for compensation to
the
auctioneer it seems to any further
questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you I have no further pink cards on uh
HB 573 is there anyone else I'm sorry
513 um is there anyone else who would
like to testify on SP
513 seeing none I'll close the public
thank you Mr chairman and uh one last
time I am Grant AI here to introduce
Senate Bill 514 on behalf of Senator
Pearl the prime sponsor and on behalf of
all our Senators thank you again for the
courtesy of letting staff introduce
these bills on their behalf New
Hampshire imposes a normal yield tax of
10% on the stumpage value of Timber at
the time it's cut which then goes to the
municipality there's an exemption for
the first 10,000 board feet for the
landowner's own use for construction up
to 20 cords of fuel
uh fuel wood per year or the equivalent
of wood chips this creates a lot of
paperwork and up to a 15-day delay for
many small harvesting operations meant
for the landowner's property for Which
towns get very little Revenue it's also
confusion on how to calculate the
equivalent of 10,000 Bo feet or 20 cords
of wood chips s514 increases the
personal use exemptions by 50% and
cleans up the equivalent Language by
replacing it with an exemption of 300
tons of whole tree chips as you can see
from the fiscal note that would have a
negligible impact on local revenues for
instance the tax on 10 additional cords
of firewood would only be about 10 bucks
the Senate Ways and Means Committee
adopted an amendment that changed the
limit on wood chips from 30 tons to 300
tons which the sponsors and committee
felt was a better equivalent to the
board feet limit SP 514 would reduce
time and paperwork for land owners
harvesting a small number of trees on
the their own land and for local
officials who are putting a lot of work
for very little Revenue Senator Pearl
thanks you for your consideration and
support of s SP 514 thank
you thank
you questions representative
Aly yes
on I'm skeptical of this particularly
the last paragraph in which someone can
clearcut a whole parcel and and uh we
don't 300 tons of whole wood chips
sounds like an awful lot and these days
wood chips go for more
um this would be for personal use not
for sale this would um no that
particular one is convert the use of the
land uh after securing building permits
subdivision or zoning permits Etc so
that's not that's personal business use
I'm I'm sorry I don't have
a which line are you looking at on I'm
looking at lines
20 uh 3 to
26 okay that's existing
statute that's not a change in the bill
itself and whether the existing
statute's correct again that that's for
you to decide but it's not it is
also multiplying by three it looks like
what anybody else can
take because you added
in you increased the logs you increase
the cords I guess I guess it isn't by
three but the 300 tons of whole wood
chips uh is supposed to be equivalent to
30 cords of wood that was the decision
the committee made I couldn't I couldn't
speak to that well I'm going to want to
talk with my essor about this
before because the timber tax was
created to compensate the towns for the
fact that the forests were in current
use and that they weren't able to to tax
it except at extremely low rates so the
idea was when the timber comes off as a
product then you tax
it so there's something arai either on
one end or the other of
this in terms of of compensation what
what's your question represent El me or
is it a would you believe would you
believe well okay I'm staff I don't
believe
anything uh representative fellows um
yes so I I think I'm surprised that
there's not a fiscal note in here I do
understand that this bill was amended
and I looked up to see how it was
amended and the Amendment did just one
thing it's in line
21 um in where it says and 300 tons
right now it initially it said 30 tons
so that's a substantial increase I think
there is a fiscal impact here on the uh
municipalities because just the little
change that goes from 20 to 30 cords if
you you said the tax on a cord was about
$10 I believe so let me check that or I
we don't know the rates you said
something yeah 10 additional cords the
tax would be about $10 then you think
the tax is $1 per cord that's the
information I was given well I I think
we need more information about like what
the rates are because I I do I
personally understand what a cord looks
like but when you get into the board
feet I don't know what that is and 300
tons must have have that's quite a bit
the other thing is initially this bill
before it was amended that it said um
10,000 board feet and 20 cords of wood
or the equivalent in whole tree chips
now this instead of saying
or it's it says what we just
had um beefed up
plus a the whole in in addition to that
300 tons of wood chips this is a
substantial increase in what it was
before so I think we really need to
understand the impact on this uh for
municipalities yeah that wording again I
can't speak to the policy that's that's
a prerogative of people who were elected
uh and I'm not one of them uh but the uh
problem was that calculating what that
equivalent
was uh
was inserting complexity into the
process whereas if you just put down a
number and you say how many board feet
how many cords and how many wood chips
that gives the local tax assessors you
know okay you're at 31 you're at 298 you
pay a little bit of tax you pay none um
it was simpler to give them a number
than have them try to figure out how
many wood chips a wood chip could
chip
representative PL would you believe that
I looked up what a ton what a cord of
wood weighs and it comes out to 2 to
5,000 pounds depending on what kind of
wood I guess which is uh uh which is one
to 2 and A2 tons and so if you multiply
30 cords by that you wind up with 30 to
75 tons rather than 300 and yes chips
would have more air in it but the weight
shouldn't change so where did the 300
tons come from uh that that was an
amendment adopted in committee the those
members would have to say why they got
number representative roachford followed
by representative Lop thank you Mr
chairman looking at the 30 cords and 30
tons of whole tree chips to me that
makes sense in that when you cut a tree
you're going to bring anches and tops
that are
not considered cordwood so would you
agree that you know adding that 300 tons
of chips would
just is actually being allowing the land
owner to do a cleaner job in their Woods
to uh clean up the trees and the tops
without having to trigger an uh attacks
I would agree that that sounds like a
policy consideration thank
thank you Mr chair I'm wondering if for
the work session um is I'm like I know
also how much a cord of wood is and if
you're burning 30 cords of wood for
personal purpose your house is got to be
like I don't know 15,000 ft it it just
seems like it's
it's like we're Ways and Means so this
seems unbelievable to me that this would
be for personal purpose and that that
should not be taxed because you're not
selling it so I would need some
testimony during a work session that
that this that these numbers correspond
to what would be a personal use for a
okay
out
copy I gave you you have two copies
here
yep
it hello good afternoon uh for the
record I'm Jason stock I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire Timberland
Owners Association and thank you for the
opportunity to come and testify a lot of
very good questions and I hope to answer
answer them also with me today um Dr is
here to prepare is also here today to
prepare and prepared excuse me to answer
some of the what are the tax
implications of this on the municipal
level and I also have a a individual
that's in the in the logging business
that can talk about okay what are we
what are we talking about you know cords
chips board feet so hopefully I have
enough folks here that can answer the
questions but I I want to introduce our
association we're a landowner Forest
industry Association I like to say we
represent the entire food chain land
owners loggers Foresters wood using
Mills and uh we we actually sought this
sought this legislation to address an
issue that we're that that we're having
um with small Timber sales I know there
was concern about large clearcuts things
of that nature what we're talking about
here and when you look at these volumes
what we're talking about are small
Timber
sales projects that are usually measured
in days not weeks or months of
activity um and you know in the case of
personal use I know I have a I have
members uh who have outdoor wood boilers
and they they burn wood as their primary
source um and they easily burn 15 15
cords a year for their for in this case
a 25 2500 square foot home so you know
to kind of put things in perspective
there you know and they also Heat their
water and do some other things with it
but my point is is that the volumes
we're talking about if you're not in the
woods business it may seem like a lot
300 tons you know 30 cords in our in our
world these are these are small volum
volumes these are for small and when you
look at the land you know the land
conversion piece and and representative
Aly uh referenced um section five which
is land conversion what we're talking
about basically are small small house
Lots or if I'm going to put a b put a
barn on the back of my I call up the
logger I'm going to put in a barn in a
little riding arena for my kids this is
the type of projects we're talking about
I passed out a copy of the intent to cut
um in New Hampshire Timber's consider
standing Timber is considered real real
property and it's subject to Municipal
Taxes it's 10% of that tax in New
Hampshire um that tax is assessed at the
time of severance it's it's assessed
when you cut it this was done quite
intentionally because the the practice
up into the 40s where if you wanted to
maintain a low tax bill you just cut all
your wood and you just keep cutting the
wood and you don't have trees out there
no Timber to assess I have a small tax
bill isn't that fine well the decision
was made and I think quite appropriately
by the the general court let's defer
that tax and assess it at the time of
severance therefore that
landowner um they can they can they
would they can now grow those trees and
they pay that tax when they go in and
and cut that wood which also happens to
coincide with when they're getting P
when they're getting paid for that wood
so it worked out well and talking to
some of the very old Foresters that were
around back in the 30s and 20s they will
tell you that one of the few things
there were several policies in in State
history that really promoted forestry
and Forest conservation and um and in
fact that the title of this law is the
forest conservation and Taxation um Act
was was the fact that this tax is
deferred until the time of severance so
that's kind of the history of it so when
it comes time to tax this because this
tax is deferred and a a town can't they
don't know when they're not mind readers
they're not going to know when I'm going
to harvest it we have What's called the
intent to cut process and that's the
form I I I distributed so when it comes
time to do a Timber sale before I can
Harvest my Forester logger or I'm
comfortable enough as a land owner I
fill out this form and I'm telling the
town all right I'm going to be
conducting a Timber Harvest um and
here's what you can expect in terms of
species and products and I submit that
to the town the town reviews it they
make sure a everyone that owns the
property has signed it B that it is
properly filled out and also that there
aren't any tax leans on the property and
and if I'm not if I'm in a rear and
taxes then what they can do is they can
require a bond but they they look to
ensure that the tax is pro that the
form's completely is properly filled out
the town legally has 15 days to do that
they have 15 days essentially two weeks
to do that and that's an important an
important point for a large traditional
Timber sale that that generally is not a
problem because of the planning that can
go into it but when you're dealing with
some of these smaller projects where
again it's a day or two it's a day or
two to do a
project um waiting 15 days to have the
contractors say I'm doing a project on
my property I'm I'm clearing an area for
a barn and a riding rink for my my kids
we're going to get a we're going to get
a pony and we're going to have a riding
rink we clear that my neighbor down the
road says says hey I'd like to do a
little clearing um as well we've got
some trees we'd like to clear out not a
lot can your can your logging contractor
come over and do it well he's wrapping
up here tomorrow for him to come back
leave and then come back 15 days later
for a handful of trees operationally
just doesn't make sense um and when you
look at the tax implications there's not
a lot of taxes in involved and again Dr
can get into the the volume or the the
dollars and cents but for for a
contractor to mobilize and demobilize
you're looking at 5,000 about $5,000
these days and to do that
for a small volume of trees it isn't it
isn't
economical and so what we looked at is
we said all right let's look at these
personal exemptions are they still
applicable in today's world do they
still make sense and that's what
prompted us to look at say all right
let's increase the the exemptions for
both the personal use but also for that
that paragraph five the the the land
um I'm just looking at my notes here so
I I did a dive into the
20120 department of revenue report of
cut data so I fill out my form my intent
to cut I send it to Dr I send it to the
town they review it they say yes Jason
looks great you're up to date on your
taxes you've signed this they they they
sign off on it I do my project a copy
goes to the Department of
Revenue we do the timber sale and then
at the end of the sale I have a I have a
form I send of what was actually
harvested because again you know
measuring trees is not an exact science
and so that's called the report of cut
that report of cut goes to the town the
town says oh okay you did not Harvest
100,000 board feet of eastern white pine
you only harvested 80 that's what we
will assess your tax at where they get
that value the dollar so you have a do
you have a volume and the Department of
Revenue twice a year does a survey of
the industry of land owners and of Mills
and they find and to to deter terine
what is the term is stumpage what is
white pine stumpage that's a tree
growing growing in the forest not the
log in the Woodyard but a tree in the
forest what is what are these stumpage
values they provide those to the town
the town says okay Jason did 880,000
board feet and that our stumpage to use
round numbers our stumpage our stumpage
survey shows that it's $10 $10
uh per thousand board feet so they the
towns get this they have a range because
some not all not all Timber lots are are
created equal they have a range and
they'll say wow that was really nice
that was a really nice stand of wood it
was easy to get at we're going to put
them on the higher end well that that
was on the backside of some rock Rocky
Mountain and it was pretty nasty
scraggle wood will put them on the lower
end but based on that they assigned they
they send me a tax bill and that's but
off of that report a cut Dr tracks all
this and so I I did I went in and looked
at dr's did a request and got a copy of
there the latest copy I had was 2020 the
2020 tax year um report of cut report of
cut data
and again to put things in perspective
in 2020 there were
2,326 s report of cuts filed so these
were these were report of cuts that were
filed or Timber you know where someone's
contemplating Timber or Timber
Harvest almost 400 of those 398 there
was no activity either the project
didn't happen or the project started but
didn't didn't complete and would be
carried over but almost 400 of that 20
2,327 report of cuts
there was no
volume
uh of those of the of the total volume
of intent to Cuts or report of cuts
675 were 1 to 300 tons were reported 1
to 300 tons were were reported as total
volumes so again to kind of give you a
kind of the universe here that we're
talking about so Timber sales happen
across the state there are a lot of them
many people are unaware of this because
they happen in the woods and and uh
they're not usually right in your right
in your face but there are there's a lot
of Forestry activity that occurs across
our state um when you look at the and I
did a quick quick analysis saying all
right what's what's a board foot worth
what in a board foot that's although it
sounds like jargon let me find my here
it is a board foot is a it's a physical
it's just what it sounds like one foot
square by 1 inch thick that's a it's a
volumetric measure of Timber a cord I
think I I think there's a couple folks
here that burn some firewood four feet
high a stack four feet high by four feet
wide by 8 feet 8 ft long and of course a
ton is a ton
um so so 300 tons of wood chips uh wood
chips right now are about a if you can
if you can find a market for it because
these typically go to biomass power
plants if you can find a market that's a
big if we'll say you get about a dime
the stumpage value is about a dime a ton
so that's 300 tons at a dime a ton is
$30 in stumpage
value uh again assum you're you're you
have a 10% tax 10% your ways and means
10% of $30 we're talking about $3 in
taxes um on the 300
tons volumetrically that's four four
what they call boxes that would be four
trucks or excuse me 10 excuse me 10
trucks of of wood
chips um the on the board footage side
when we're looking at here when we go to
15,000 those are two log that would be
15,000 board feed is about two log
trucks these are two log trucks worth of
logs so again it's not a huge huge
parade of of vehicles um and as was
referenced earlier the
chipwood usually is the tops it's the
limbs it's the smaller limbs it's the
branches it's the brush basically that
gets chipped so I may take out two
truckloads of logs when I take that tree
out of the woods I cut that log off
which is the trunk of the tree the rest
of that tree i i i i chip it again my
client the landowner who wants to build
the barn or wants to clear a small lot
for a home they don't want to have brush
out there to contend with so I clear I
chipped
that and again is is is when the bill
was
introduced trying to explain a cal the
calculations from cords board footage to
tons we'll just say can be challenging
I've looked at tables and charts and you
can get into all kind you can really go
down a rabbit hole looking at what's the
species what's the weight Etc so the
part of the rationale was saying 300 ton
and 300 tons and again usually on these
jobs whyatt and 300 tons is the chips
always are com because you because of
the nature of the job that that
homeowner wants those chips they want
they don't want the brush there they
want it gone so it's always kind of
coming in even if you're going to cut a
couple loads of logs or even some
firewood you want that you want that
chipwood
out on the on the board
footage the we're going Jason can I stop
you for a minute uh you put three to
four minutes you're at about 10 minutes
god um if you can just kind of final
summarize quickly that I appreciate it I
will 5,000 board
feet 5,000 board feet um that that
equates to about aund and if it's Pine
my calculation looking at kind of the
the published it's about
$110 for for Pine Red Oak which is worth
a little bit more it's
$175 so again what we're talking about
here on these projects not a huge amount
of Revenue um and again the whole intent
of this is to keep things moving keep
and make it cleaner clearer and cleaner
and easier I'm happy apologize for going
over problem get talking trees and I get
excited and keep going that was helpful
uh
information uh representative PL I just
want to say thank you this had me
stumped representative fell so so thank
you you told us the what you told us
were were the values of selling this
property the the the wood correct when
you were saying um the oak is you know
5,000 board feet of Oak
$175 you're telling is that the price
that it sells for or is that the tax
Timber tax on
it that
is that is the tax so 5,000 board feet
of r Oak Red Oak is around $350 per
th000 board feet that has a stumpage
value of
$1,750 10% of 10% of that is
$175 I I need clarification on that
please 5,000 Bo feet of red oak is worth
350 per th so 350 * 5
gives you
$1,750 that's the stumpage value that's
the Delta between current law and what
this bill is
1,750 the tax is
did you have a followup yeah yeah I'm
not getting this the let me ask the
questions so you have one if you we want
to use 1,000 that's fine so one thou
we're talk going to talk about one kind
of wood like Oak let me do that so 1,000
board
foot of board feet of Oak is you want
want to tell me the tax or you that no
the the market value the stumpage value
for your 1,000 board fee to O is
$350
right Timber tax on that that's the
that of the
350 well no it's 300 yes in this case
with 1,000 if 1,000 board feet M it
would be 10% % of
that so are all the taxes 10% of do you
have a
chart um I know Dr can provide copies of
what they assess at but it's 10 10% is
the timber tax so that it's a pretty
simple chart 10% but they do have the
assessed values in their their
reports okay I'm going to uh um do you
have a just to put just so everyone
knows the timing I'm trying to finish by
by 4:00 because I do have people that
need to leave at that time um
so representative um rord follows by
representative Aly yes thank you and I
do have one more pink card just short
ones oh you do have another pink all
right yeah so I'll just ask one of my
two questions maybe the next pink card
can answer this I uh just I have some
loggers in my community as my
constituents and when the whole Burgess
power plant issue came up uh talking
about a source for the biomass like you
said there's not a lot of places you can
bring it but even when they could bring
it somewhere um they were saying there's
really not a lot of value in it anyway
but by the time you pay for fuel and
truck it all over the North country and
and and otherwise there's really not a a
lot of value in it so um that being said
a could you confirm that and B uh it if
that's true it doesn't seem like 300
tons of whole chip trees have a whole
lot of monetary value to them
them correct and the the value I
assigned a ton of wood chips is 30 is is
a dime so it's $30 is the stumpage value
10% of that which is your Timber tax is
lot represent Aly yes on what does this
also
cover the large
Timber
Cutters that we've got some of in New
Hampshire and there are a lot of in
Maine but it it wouldn't because of the
the size limits again when you look at
these size
limits these are small Timber
sailes with you know two we're talking
two truckloads of logs there you know
two truckloads of logs is that's the
scope of things things that we're
talking about so it's not the
huge you know it's not again I know
there was a concern about clear cutting
it's it's not large moonscapes it's it's
a couple loads of logs and the chipwood
associated with that and it's although
10 10 boxes might seem like a lot those
branches and and twigs fill up a box
pretty darn
quickly okay thank
you thank you again I apologize for
going no problem it's been very helpful
and uh last um pin card I have is
Dr afternoon uh my name is Adam denor
I'm the assistant director of the
municipal and property division at Dr um
part of the responsibility of the
municipal and property division is to
help administer the timber
tax so as Jason mentioned the actual tax
impact of this amendment is
negligible uh what I did was I took the
last four years of Timber tax data so
that's going back to
2020 um and Tred to extract from all of
the reports that we received for every
single one of these years just those
reports which would have qualified under
this exemption and then determine an
actual tax amount um when you take that
apart into four separate years and then
into 259 taxing districts because we're
talking about about every possible Town
unincorporated that could have a report
filed with them it's about
$200 per town that this would that the
impact would be so it's rather small and
of course many of those towns are not
going to have Timber intents um and the
one variable that's very difficult to
control for and looking at this is the
number of these operations that would
actually qualify for the exemption it's
important to note this is about land
conversion it's not about Forest
management so if you have a nice stand
of Oak that you want to slowly cut away
at and sell that's not what this
exemption is for it's for clearing a
building lot or as Jason mentioned a
barn or riding arena something like that
you're there to kind of make space to to
do something else with that that
property as opposed to just manage your
forest and avoid Timber tax while doing
so so it's it's about $200 um per town
found anybody
else yes representative Ames just to ask
uh do you have that information that you
just gave in some kind of form that can
be shared with us absolutely yeah yeah
it would be good sounds
good repres bolon and as following up to
that and by
Town um because I live in the town of uh
Plymouth and we've I've signed quite a
few of these I'm also a select board
member up there sure and I think some
towns might be more effective than
others but yeah no that's definitely
true and I think we could probably break
here Notch
Grace thank you Mr chair H GRA with the
municipal Association um we are neutral
on the bill um I just want to comment on
that we did reach out to some assessors
on it um when it came across our desk um
and they had done the same math that Dr
did which Dr will provide you um it was
a very minimal cost
and even though it was it was $200 per
town that was collected in like5 and $10
increments over multiple cuts um largely
when they broke it down so it ended up
being the case that the administrative
burden of collecting $5 from somebody
was more more than more than all the
paperwork required for it so um we are
neutral on that but I'm happy to take
any questions if the committee has it
thank
you thank you I think we're good thank
you is there anyone else that would like
to testify on
hbb we're in the SBS now s SP
514 saying n I'll close the public
pun you know setting expectations
is